[Musique]
dior salut tout le monde bonsoir à tous
et bienvenue pour ce nouveau stream donc
un nouveau script j'ai envie de dire
demi finales de ce pitch s on voit les
joueuses qui sont à l'écran vous dit
bonsoir à tous désolés pour le tout
petit retard mais comme je suis sur le
nouveau ça tape ces quelques petits
trucs que j'ai pas que que j'ai que j'ai
fait dernier moment quelques j'avais
oublié qu'il fallait faire pour pour ces
stream là j'avais l'impression d'avoir
bien ce to set up comme il faut bien
comme il faut et c'était pas c'était pas
forcément top et donc et donc match
aujourd'hui au sommet entre kosteniuk
erwin il a donc c'est d'après moi un d
après moi la plus belle affiche qu'on
est dans ce dans ce speech est féminin
c'est un peu la finale avant l'heure
même si c'est pas dit qu'elles gagneront
à l'affût de la finale mais je pense que
c'est les deux plus forts joueuse de la
compétition qu'on va voir ce soir et on
va suivre du côté de
de vanina que je vois pas alors que je
devais normalement en ami alors au pire
on va trouver kosteniuk parce que cette
chaise queen vanina sa mise à j'arrivais
pas à mettre la main dessus
on va suivre et 20 mais voila voila ça
démarre
ça démarre immédiatement premier coup de
la partie donc attendez à pourquoi
est-ce que j'ai le truc dans deux sens
différents attendait une petite seconde
ok j'ai compris le problème
j'ai compris le problème les amis c'est
que j'avais mis le truc dans le mauvais
sens c'est bien ce que je disais voilà
on est bon j'avais le truc à l'envers et
donc on est bon donc on va juste revenir
sous couverture cavaliers 3 des 5 g 3 et
6 fou j'ai deux fous gk donc l'idée là
des noirs c'est de donner le fou de
cases blanches et de jouer avec les
pions sur carte blanche au centre de
l'échiquier
si jamais un petit souci dans le chatt
n'hésitez pas à m'écrire immédiat mal
comme je vous disais c'est nouveau set
up et donc pour chaque nouveau stream en
fait il ya un petit il ya un petit
problème possible donc ces trois donc
comme vous voyez un toujours ce petit
mur la face au fossé important et donc
les blancs pour le moment qui ont donné
le pion c4eva llena donc il ya un fond
plus mais vanina qui est un problème de
connexion quand même il faut le faut le
souligner elle a que deux barres de
connexion alors on verra si ça une si ça
aide ok il ya un problème avec l'icône
du bas exactement merci charpentier
merci charpentier voilà on va mettre ça
comme ça voilà ça c'est parfait
merci charpentier pour les petits
feedback est annoncé comme usé nouveau
ce nouveau nouveau set up s'est jamais
jamais jamais évident et donc full méca
donc ok l'idée des blancs ça va être de
jouer à perdre de fouilles de récupérer
le client c4 pour faire simple et l'idée
des noirs ça va être soit synchro
champions s'est cassé hier de faire que
les blancs et le plus de mal possible à
récupérer et si ils leurs paires de bas
de leur père dans des conditions dans
des bonnes conditions se servant des
conditions les noirs ont réussi à
égaliser alors ici pour les noirs ya eu
4 comme option éventuellement pour
fermer la diagonale du fou et protéger
le fiancé 6 on peut aussi imaginer puis
on prend fou prend car il prend dame
prend et rock
donc ça c'est un petit peu pour
illustrer les variantes et donc ça alors
je sais pas exactement là si ça
fonctionne ou parent mais en gros ça
pourrait être l'idée mon latin français
car c'est probablement pas le point et
peut-être tour des uns ou peut-être dame
tremblay cette même mieux mais juste ça
c'est un exemple de ce que vous devrez
réussir à faire les noirs c'est à dire
échangé de coups de canne blanche par
exemple reperdent le pion c4 mais ici
palmarès borne aurait une meilleure
structure parce qu'on a deux pions liée
contre deux pions un palier et donc des
pions faible donc ça ce serait
typiquement ce que pourrait vouloir les
les noirs mais à la paperie est la
rocqué prise prise prises et tour c'est
comme je vous disais un j'ai pas vu
exactement ce qui était les variantes
dans l'opposition donc c'est pas une
critique du coup quand je dis à la
paperie c'est juste bon à la paperie
quoi hockey est donc là qu'est ce qui se
passe donc on a structure de pions plus
ou moins symétrique parce que y'a que
des pions les uns en face des autres
cependant assez 4 contre ces trois et on
a deux cavaliers contre de fou donc
généralement on dit que les foules sont
meilleurs mais ici à peut-être cette
caste b3 qui peut être intéressante
cependant très bien joué fois trois
foulées cadre de la part de kosteniuk
qui réussit va installer son fou ici et
finalement à bien couvrir son pion et
maintenant elle va mettre la tour en d1
et finalement ce cavalier b3 à elle peut
manger à 5 maintenant attention elle
peut manger à 5 dont tour d un mais il
va falloir regarder si cai prend à
s'inquiète un coup ici parce que si ça a
un coût c'est quand même un tueur l'idée
c'est qu'à valider 3 est reparti avec le
pion donc damas quatre menaces
lecavalier
on imagine que qu'elle reparte vers
détroit et maintenant les noirs veulent
à 5 et donc avoir un vrai plus en plus
alors c'est pas encore énormément mais
c'est toujours un pion dame assise donc
les blancs qui contrôle quand même bien
ce pion puisque le fou contrôler la case
à 8 et la dame vient s'installer devant
le pion à 7 un coup comme d'hab des six
pourraient être envisageables pour
échanger les dames un jour mais il
serait très difficile de pousser le pion
b c'est pour ça peut-être qu'elles
jouent aux cadres donc elle ferme la
diagonale du fou
elle ferme la diagonale du fou et elle
va se permettre peut-être de faire du
dam sac et un jour peut-être pas là me 5
adam fera à 7 non va dire un jour de
chasse et la dame et d'envoyer le pion
au moins jusqu'à 5 on va dire chassez le
fou est peut-être après du dab le simple
pion c3 sera faible enfin bon
probablement ça peut devenir un bon
piont passé dans un avenir très lointain
parce que c'est vrai que cette case à 3
pour le moins il sera dur à passer mais
bon s'il perd il en a quatre et que le
faux obligé de le sur le surveiller ce
sera déjà ça de réussi alors h4 jouer
quand on bouge le pion âge comme ça j'ai
avancé qu'on sait pas quoi faire en
blitz
mais elles donnent le coup au noir alors
est ce qu'elle va jouer
key des cinq peut-être paria ces
emprises de 3 à eux trois
intéressant à elle joue sur le fait que
le pion h coup qu'on a dit un petit peu
comme ça à coups de beats parce qu'on
sait pas quoi faire et elle joue sur le
fait que ce pion soit parti en h4 donc
le pion g3 n'est plus couvert et elle
fait que trois absents promptement f2 et
elle veut gagner le pion g3 food et 6
intermédiaire alors là est peut-être qu
on prend acte de l'échec intermédiaires
et c'est vrai que ça aura eu le mérite
d'un petit peut affaiblir le roi blanc
surtout que c'est elle prend la tour il
y aura un clouage sur la colonne des
donc j'imagine que noir vont prendre je
vois pas trop quelle est la plus value
de ne pas prendre ici donc ses prix
tourcoing f2 très probable et maintenant
peut-être un coup comme d'hab et 6 comme
on le disait on veut échanger les dames
ramener le pion paris c'est pousser
cependant il sera très difficile comme
je disais date de passer la casse b4
donc c'est l'inconvénient elle fait
d'amener cet ajout sur le clouage et
elle veut jouer peut-être sur du
cavalier g4 par la suite non ça se peut
dans jcs et g3 toiture est fait un
caillou 3 et à piéger 4 sa menace mais
quoique kg cas peut être une idée en
tout cas c'est fou il a du mal à bouger
tous rêvent d impossible on pourra
toujours pas bougé le fou parce que les
noirs on prend les deux tours quoique
quoique peut-être tour à tour effaré
impôts ici pour pour partir avec la tour
et sur quoi les ordres et rue quelque
chose c'est une position vraiment
compliqué à évaluer parce qu'on a du mal
à et tour c6 pas possible dans le chat
parce que le fou contrôle donc tout ceci
ce n'est pas une menace ici position
vraiment vraiment vraiment compliqué se
fout des six
escou g2 qui sont quand même assez fort
à la fedama 3 alors damas trois ils
consolident le fou mais d'un autre côté
elle menace pas de le bouger donc dames
6 maintenant sur tours f1 il y aura bien
me 3 échecs et le fou est toujours tout
et il est menacé et peut-être que l'idée
ici pour les noirs la menace était un
coup comme cavani eu quatre bons fous 17
un coup candidats ici amusez-vous
bessette la tourbe et 8 fo prend dès mi
temps reprend d un échec
et donc il n'ya pas de souci donc faux
v7 n'en fermerai rien j'ai pas trop aimé
d'art à 3 après juste un petit coup
d'oeil avec avec l'ordi puisque je veux
pas critiquer les coûts les joueurs
c'est les meilleurs
ouais alors dire recommandé tour eiffel
forme quand même qu'ils étaient vraiment
logique et dames trois dames à 3 du coup
il as me recommander et l'a4 jouer alors
l'idée c'est que sur qu'il prend le 4
elle veut faire tout à eux deux
wen ont à leur tour de il devait y avoir
un truc genre tout reprend des six tout
bêtement
ça puait la défaite donc ça échange ça
échange et on se retrouve avec quoi
toujours un pion plus pour les noirs le
food et 6 toujours cloué le pion g3
emprise
le seul problème des noirs c'est ce
cavalier mais sur damas trois y avoir
cavaliers c5
parce que fou prend ses 5 % des 1 et
voudrait elle voudra repartir vers 4
avec le cavalier tous menacés donc dams
est évidemment elle laisse pas faire et
tours 8 donc les noirs qui perdent le
clouage sur le fou mais qui vont pouvoir
leur gagner avec tour cédé 8 au prochain
donc j'imagine tour cédé 8 et c'est vrai
que c'est torah et mieux place en 8
quand ces 8
il ya eu le petit rock détour à loreley
à tour prend des six tours prend des six
daims prend des six daims preuve cet
échec qui fera une double attaque donc
pas jouable cependant kessé saint cloud
dont on parlait tout à l'heure lui tout
à fait jouable menace la dame et l'idée
au prochain c'est de faire cavalier ou
quatre menaces tour cavaliers il semble
que vanina
gagné la première partie sans trop de
difficultés elle a pris le pion au début
il ya eu serait ok attendait entreprend
d1 ses qualités plus d'1 me quatre
échecs est une vraie menace ici je pense
que je partirai pour dames et quatre
échecs perso avec les noirs pour rentrer
dans la finale
simplifier la position et la finale avec
une qualité de plus elle doit pas être
super compliqué à réaliser
alors elle fait tout repeint maximaliste
elle joue pour tour g1 pour ces
maximaliste 700 gars jouer après mais
bon moi j'aurai les joueurs étaient un
peu plus de trois tours à deux donc
empêche tour g1
pour le moment les blancs qui défendent
les cases importante en risque vanina va
faire du km5 d'amay fin d'un match un
possible à la aussi damn 4 à tout moment
qui est jouable
les blancs qui consolide la position
affront dame bien ici peut peut-être
être un coup quoique non j'aime pas trop
parce qu'ils auraient dame prend f7 et
sa menace dame g7 maths à moi je ferais
dame e41 perso les mecs on m'a expliqué
ça on a expliqué ça il ya bien longtemps
quant à du matériel en plus des changes
les pièces assez calme qualité de pions
plus je m'embêterait pas fait après les
gouts et les couleurs mais je m'en
remettrai pas à ma me risquer de me
prendre un cheapos on sait jamais ça
peut arriver un chapeau peuvent toujours
arriver
en tout cas je serais plus plus prudent
et plus pleutre donc h5 bon il n'ya pas
grand chose a commenté les noirs sont
complètement gagnant il faut finir le
job je vois bien kosteniuk tenté un
retour à cette ça marche pas à leur tour
2 qui va arriver donc peut-être tour à 7
quand même tenté de faire une contre
attaque elle fait tour b 2 elle attend
c'est sûr que son idée c'est de planter
un moment donné un piège changer cette
un truc comme ça ça n'a jamais marché
mais c'est ce que tu espères faire aucun
état d'âme en f2 elle est un peu obligé
jean pas d'autres cases pascal g iii qui
est sous pression aussi
donc je pense d'autres casques dame f2
bon elle a fini par abandonner cette
façon il ya les tours g4 qui arrive et
on prend g3 à alléger réussi à fermer la
partie qu'on voulait voir
j'ai fermé la mauvaise allons fermer
l'ancien et on part pour une sicilienne
alors est-ce qu'il va y avoir
bref c'est jouer avec fougue et cinq
échecs car il est 17 rock arrivé trois
ou quatre aussi je pense toucher quatre
tours angers troyes était aussi assez a
assez convaincant et donc on est un
genre de rosso limo alors si j'ai un
genre deux parce que la route au niveau
normalement c'est sûr qu'avec 3 kgs ses
six levers 5
et après tout séparé entre laon d'autres
dont la salle assez lakanal c'est pas
sympa car elle son col ski c'est la clé
17 chez plus le nom case que ça steve
carell souk au lycée avec fu 17
s'arrêter et 17 c'était encore autre
chose
en tout cas en tout cas les blancs qui
les blancs qui ont rauque et joue avec
des quatre un peu comme dans une
sicilienne ouvertes et les noirs qui
joue un truc qui pourrait ressembler un
dragon de loin même un dragon d'or
quand il te dira un dragon age of
mélanger puisqu'elle poids à 6b 5 qui
arrive donc ça pourrait ressembler à des
genres de moins de nage d'orgue de
dragons alors les blancs qui ont le pion
aux 134 qui prend l'espace au centre
plus que ceux de l'adversaire mais les
noirs qui vont jouer avec des cinq fours
bessette qui vont venir s'en prendre à
ce pion qui vont faire cavaler tour
c'est 8
le cavalier qui va peut-être jaillir un
jour pourquoi pas verra car actuellement
ce qui se passe à voir cavaliers des
cinq ans l'idée souvent c'est que sur
qui et prend pions prend on crée un pion
arriérés chez l'adversaire on gagne la
casse et 6 c c'est pour ça qu'on fait
qu'aider 5
quelque part on empêche enfin on empêche
la prise pas forcément intéressante pour
les noirs mais ici les noirs vous faut
bessette avec l'idée m'a tout simplement
de gagner un pion aux cavaliers pros f6
fou prend f6 maintenant le fou le
cavalier peut être un peu sous pression
mais surtout le pion aux 4 qui est
menacée
il est protégé et la dame b6 donc
maintenant aux menaces
un truc comme karim prend le 4 avec les
noirs donc floue 3 qui défend la
diagonale et dames c'est cette donc
commence à jouer sur la colonne s'est
alors est ce que les blancs ont joué les
tours c'est un c4 qui peut être une idée
ouais elle part pour ça attention
cavaliers à 4 bien jouer menace le pion
b2 et vanina qui va calculer ses 4 quand
même à mon avis et surtout prendre faire
qu on prend des cinq donc c4 est ce que
c'est jouable ou pas c'est la question
vahina qui doit être en train de
calculer ça parce que sur b3 j'ai peur
même qui réalisent ces trois tours à ses
8 et ongles un lecavalier sur ces 3 donc
je pense c4 est vraiment candidat qui
prend ses 4èmes et qui prend b2 dam des
trois qui est prompt c4 france et 4 puis
on prend ces quatre ans et 4 dames des
dames 17 et ça semble court donc ces
quatre pas jouable il a joué tout à
lajoux est tombé 1 mm entoure ces 8 mai
en session qui en prise elle fait ses
quatre maintenant alors à noter que l'on
prend est pas joie parce qu'elle
cavaliers emprise et donc les blancs qui
réussissent à faire ces quatre mais pas
forcément dans les meilleures meilleures
conditions le 5 le cavalier qui va
repartir
elle peut faire cavalier de puisque sur
d'armes français capturés b3 et ya pas
de manière de rebondir pour attaquer le
fou donc carrillo de jouable kaïs et 2
aux siens
elle fait carré lieu de rs que d'armes
français quatre heures détroit et il ya
plus casse pour la date pas pour
attaquer le fou pour pour faire quelque
chose d'intéressant que prisent prises
des 5 est maintenant le pion des cinq
qui en sueur elle masque éprouvé 5 ça
semble impossible de défendre puisqu'il
a attaqué deux fois et il est protégé 0
x alors après on peut soit partir pour
une idée de se dire on va faire b4 on va
pousser à b et finalement ses pions ils
sont doubles est donc c'est peut-être
pas si fort ou alors on cherche un point
intermédiaire genre cavaliers ccaf qui
est prend des cinq qui prend 1,3 l'idée
surtout reprend ce que peut-être de
jouer dam des six ouvrages donc et c'est
cette idée inquiets au 8 mais il semble
que les blancs ici soit gagnant parce
qu'on menace avec le cavalier de
rebondir vers f6 tour prend 1,8 plus ou
moins forcé pour prendre et 1 et 1 on a
une qualité de plus donc avalé ces trois
quarts ils ces trois intéressant menace
vraiment le pion b5
menace vraiment le pion b5 des cinq joué
par la joueuse russe et donc on va voir
on va voir comment comment comment ça
évolue tant d une petite seconde je dois
régler un tout petit truc en même temps
parce que la chanteuse comme ça et qu'on
a dit il n'y a pas forcément la date
c'est pas forcément la bonne date et
c'est facile à régler
donc je vais la mettre de ce pas
comprise des cinq prises des 5
donc
dames b3 donc il ya les deux pions passé
pour les blancs il ya les deux pions
passé pour les blancs et les noirs qui
vont essayer de les stopper
voilà c'est bon j'ai réussi à régler ce
problème
ok donc fou b4 alors comment est-ce que
ça se passe et ce qu'on va faire un truc
comme tout re 4 peut-être il faut faire
à faire gaffe au rebond du cavalier mais
elles font des quatre ans pris dans la
nasse fait on prend des 5 avec les
blancs vous prend des saints qui est
d'apprendre et 5 ou dame en d4
c'est vrai que là les pièces noires sont
quand même tout sous pression et à moins
qu'ils aient une chipeau de l'autre
monde
il semble que ce soit perdue et
peut-être faut tenter un truc qui est
dingue et ses trois fils qu on prend fou
prend 1,4 si on prend ça mène pas ou
même fillon prend b4 savane pas bien
loin cavaliers f4 être en b 4 tous les
coups de cavalli à tour prend des quatre
cavaliers 3 m3 au pire
tour des six il va y avoir qui prend des
six bêtement et surtour des 8 et
peut-être quelques faisons qu elle fait
pousser 5 probablement le couple humain
l'idée c'est que surtout reprend fou
prend roi prend bref à la rigueur le roi
par angers 3 et ça fait pas quand même
on va se retrouver là est en fait le roi
est assez bien protégé après elle peut
peut-être passé par derrière et faire
quelques quelques petites menaces
ok donc faisable
donc poussé cinq tours prendrait 5
semble vraiment jouable je vois pas de
contre indications font preuve de jouer
on apprend fou prend des cinq d'un cran
des cinq sa pression qu'on avait
peut-être tour ces deux échecs ici à et
suroît jamais sur un g3 n'y a pas
d'amour donc je partirai plutôt en g3
personnellement même si angers 1 il
paraît mieux protégé ça évitera de se
prendre des clous âge en g3 je vois pas
qui lui mais qu'il met en échec en fait
quitte à repartir vers h2 après elle
fait tour deux breaks été une autre
option clairement ça donne le pion à 4
après mais sa fermeté rend le roi plus
sécurisé donc dame prend est ce qu'on
fait qu'avaliser 3 sa force plus ou
moins tout reprend eu deux échecs
intermédiaire fou prend ou d'un mal cet
échec à l'endroit va partir en g3 est
tous pro 2 probablement non elle joue de
manière assez assez maligne parce
qu'elle fait tout retour c1 et elle s'en
prend aux fourneaux qui secoue autour
d'eux je suis pas sûr tu pas sûr n'en
finit pas 2e commentateurs qui est
arrivé non non ça risque pas dire a pas
de deuxième commentateur pour ce match
verra deuxième commentateur pour les
speechs s les derniers matches des
speechs junior et pour l'expliquer aux
adultes et donc tous rêvent de
donc elle protège c'est un peu le seul
cours et peut-être h5 ici va être
jouable pour les noirs avec l'idée de
faire h 4 en fait dévier le roi pour
manger la tour donc les blancs qui vont
probablement joué h4
ok dame 4tet g5 g5 tête pour jouer h 4
pour insister sur h4 parce que c'est
vrai que si elle réussit à faire h4 ça
va être un vrai problème parce que cette
tour est mal placé il ya hélas a en
ligne de mire
donc on va voir je pense g5 hk frais est
possible après avoir convoyé défense sur
g51 ya forcément des coûts déjà lire h4
nous mêmes
elle fait roi g7 je vais juste un petit
coup de
le rni welch et s'inquiétait le coup
numéro un est un coup assez logique au
final elle a joué 3 g7
je me suis perdu ok donc vous ces quatre
tours 8
et h4 alors maintenant la question c'est
ce qu'on peut faire f5 fui de f4 pour
gagner la pièce et ouais et la tour
c'était tout l'idée du truc avec 3g sept
ans gueïda madame de encore et ça
j'avais pas vu je pensais je n'ai pas vu
la meuse
je pensais qu'on gagnait la pièce direct
mais ce n'est pas le cas que quatre
pions prend dame ses sept tours f4
france et 3 prises c3 est prise 4 menace
d'un point f quatre et d'un français
qu'adam des deux tours france et 4 et
roy f3 donc pour des clous et le la tour
tous rêvent de relève de ce tour des c3
avec de forcer et il ya abandon parce
qu'ils auraient eu suroît f2 tour ces
deux donc qui faisait une une enfilade
donc on est parti c'est dans la carro
cannes je sais que oui nina était très
bien préparée sur cette variante et on
va voir on va voir ce que ça donne un
ici donc c'est l'antenne g6 ici qui est
mauvaise parce que qu'est c3 pouget sept
fous ces quatre un rock rock car lé 17
faut qu'elle fait à 6h à 4 10 et 17 des
trois cavaliers p6 dam des trois donc ça
c'est tout simplement avantage blanc et
elle a oublié sa prépa parce qu'il se
trouve que wina s'étaient préparés très
bien préparés même dans cette variante
face à vlad où elle avait égalisé en
force à lire mais jouer de la meilleure
variante avec les noirs et
et ça peut pas être ça là parce que ça
c'est réputé comme étant une mauvaise
variantes pour les noirs riches tissus
le seul à être perdus si le match ne
commence pas par 4,5
[Musique]
non probablement pas elle avait
d'ailleurs gagné la partie contre eux
vlad pour la peine avec les noirs
c'était une partie du matin chez puis
c'était au tour de gibraltar où elle est
allée là bas tu planes et vlad qui
m'avait dit que son erreur ça avait été
de de vouloir forcer la règle gardant
une grande du matin il joue pas bien le
matin balade et les mises et qu'il
aurait dû il aurait dû prendre la nulle
en fait vu que vanina avait très bien
réussi son ouverture et qu'elle est très
très forte en tactique et dans les
positions compliquées
en général il m'a dit que ça avait été
une grosse erreur de sa part que de
vouloir jouer la gagne contre elle
donc c'est pour dire que c'est une
joueuse qui est qu'ils respectent et
même des plus forts et qui est joueuse
vraiment très très dangereuse
ça c'est pour la petite anecdote sur sur
cette karo kann je suis en train
d'essayer de régler mon truc comme il
faut ce que je vois qu'il manque un peu
de caméras dédiées
c'est là en fait ok
donc l'armée vanina l'est mais les mâles
enfin ça c'est très très mauvaise
réputation comme vous dites
cette position après il ya quelques
parties dans la base et sa part pas
automatiquement mais en tout cas à
l'époque ce n'était pas censée être bon
après peut-être que ça a changé en fait
est que les ordinateurs j'ai pas réalisé
sa pire moment de vannes 2-2 fins et pas
de mémoire c'est que je sais que c'était
une variante qui était mauvaise après
qui sait peut-être qu'il ya eu un
changement entre temps qu pas au courant
mais ça semble assez assez assez sympa à
jouer avec les blancs parce qu'on a un
qui est plus quand même et on fixe
l'option est du coup
donc elle fait des quatre alors des
quatre sait jamais un pouvoir prendre à
la légère parce qu'une fois que vous
jouez des quatre vous permettez
cavaliers p6 qui est pensé qu'à mettre
la pression sur le pion des 5 ou genre
cavale et b6 tour c8 et mettre la
pression sur ces 4 et donc par la suite
si le fou par de prendre des cinq donc
des cats et jamais jamais jamais jamais
un coup qu'on joue à aller vers ici donc
compliqué compliqué comme position sur
qu'est prend 1,5 et on prend 1,5 d'en
prendre 5 imagine fous ces cinq c'est
l'idée est de gagner le pion le set
j'imagine en tout cas mes cavaliers b6
du coup c'est une question pourquoi
auquel prend 15.5 prend 1,5 et donc il
ya peut-être un truc qui m'échappe
surtout ces cinq ce que fout c'est
simple c'est quand même le coup de la
position enfin sa menace la dame et sa
menace le pion derrière ok ce qu'elle
veut c'est sur faut prendre cette
affaire qualifiée 4 il fera une double
attaque
et elle veut insister aussi sur tours fc
8 qui est une menace parce qu'elle fout
ces quatre ans prises j'ai trois
intermédiaires damage 6 mais oui disons
qu'elle peut prendre le pion aux 7
pouces et des 6-17 des mythes mais il ya
une attaque assez désagréable de l'autre
côté parce que il ya une deux trois
pièces sur le roi plus ou moins sales
donc avalé j4h quatre fous des quatre
donc on voit que
les pièces noires sont en train de
converger toutes les unes après les
autres sur le roi donc là on va se
[ __ ] en f2 et le roi blanc qui est
bien seul
alors après dans les coupes aussi via
tour f1 qui donne pas du tout envie pour
la peine cavalier d1 qui donne un peu
plus envie de 7 dans le sens où ça
libère la dame mais et ça protège bien
qu on a peut-être un peu comme tour à
tour 82 des 6 et contre attaquer sur f7
donc c'est une position très complexe il
ya des menaces des deux côtés il ya des
masses d'eau côté de tours 8 et 6 va
jouer tempo bien entendu dam des deux
contre attaques tour de bien jouer avant
de faire [ __ ] avec cet échec
elle s'est pas précipitée et c'est vrai
que c'est très très bien joué les tours
2 elle a pas vus kosteniuk à la duala du
calcul et afu prend un essai 3 bougez
voir qui est plus rien et tour de saint
jeures d'intermédiaires qui attaquent la
dame maintien fou ans et 4 pour le
moment est fou prend un excellent
d'arriver au prochain coup et donc après
damage ci soit 7.8 ok si elle réussit à
faire ça ce sera gagnant elle ramènera
la dame of 7
elle poussera 17 donc la dame qui parent
à 5,5 et là c'est la cata total le roi
qui va devoir se bouger peut-être ça va
prendre ici qui est un pro b c'est donc
là ça commence à faire déjà beaucoup de
matériel pour commencer il ya quoi il ya
trois pions et une qualité de plus et on
menace men b4 enfermement dame ici enfin
hockey amh des six forcé mais je
forcerais les changes de dames avec un
cap une qualité et
et trois points de plus et donc
constensou qui va s'incliner je dirais
que le début de match est plutôt à la
faveur de vannes il a pour le moment
elle domine venant de conseil ou pardon
qui domine plutôt ce début de match
notamment avec cette partie là dans
l'ouverture il ya que la première partie
qui est en faveur de vanina la savane
avec les noirs qui souffrent dur alors
là il a fait fuiter millions reprend en
fuite ou reprend 1,8 échec 3.812 france
et 8 échecs
mais mon foie fuite peut-être qu'elle va
faire rage et 8 ok on apprend c'est
suicidaire mayroy g8 et sur tourcoing 8
faut prendre un fou preuve de l'échec et
faut combler cette virée roi et fit seul
coup droit g8 seul coup c'est jouer
c'est bien un fouet fuite s'était
peut-être est là elle a oublié roi g8
elle a dû penser à la du calcul on
apprend et futée tout parce que là le
problème c'est qu'il ya pas d'apprendre
dame g7 matt n'existe pas et maintenant
c'est les blancs qui se retrouve menacé
par tous donc fait fuite qui était le
coup dont je parlais était peut-être la
mauvaise idée maintenant qu'on apprend
en fuite
incroyable incroyable et bruno roy prend
1,8 bon c'est peut-être encore gagnon
pour les blancs mais elle vient de
donner une pièce a fait fi 3g 8 c'était
un piège
elle l'a pas fait exprès 1 mais c'était
assez vicieux comme truc
cependant il ya peut-être encore dame g8
échec 3 bouche d'un proche s'être
apprend des six d'un projet 6 et il y
aura quand même beaucoup de pions et ce
sera quand même gagnants ouais parce que
les noirs ont du mal à se déplacer
mais causé newco et qui a pas vu le roi
g8 qui est un coup assez étonnant après
ce double échec un finalement c'est très
bien joué et donc maintenant peut-être
dameuse 5 est jouable d'amd 2 adam d2
bien joué elle menace vous prend f2 en
force d'âme f4 la finale et peut-être
pas gagnante du tout parce que les pions
seront désorganiser les pièces noires
sont très active elle le fait quand même
parce qu'elle a peut-être pas trop le
choix et en plus elle veut ne pas perdre
et là c'est vrai qu'elle a un petit
point positif c'est qu'elle peut
développer par tour à trois tours h3 ça
peut être sympa alors qu'avait lieu 3
bien joué parce que je t'ai points trois
pions prend 1,3 ça lui permet de se
ramener des pions ensemble et surtout
prend hk qui étrangers quatre fous
pranger 4 elle ira pour du tour à trois
du tour ou du tour tech par ailleurs
n'importe où et elle va essayer de faire
fructifier ses pions les fous prend b2
jouer je pensais qu'elle allait prendre
h4 personnellement
on va voir comment ça ça sa soeur
comment ça se passe tarou comme qui a
été simplifié jouable pour essayer de
gagner ce fou est allé faire du tour à 5
tours prend 1,6 à elle fait tout re 1
alors elle prépare peut-être des petits
échecs et vigilant sur cavale et prend
qu on prend ça l'effet des pions passé
lié ce qui est forcément très
intéressant pour pour vanina vanini
kemal autant il reste 27 secondes contre
une minute trente
mais là elle se défend de manière assez
extraordinaire on pensait vraiment que
la partie était perdue
alors foutez quatre menaces
désolé pour le camion qui passe devant
chez moi un petit bruit même un grand
bruit mais juste la canicule est arrivé
et du coup je avec les fenêtres ouvertes
désolé pour les quelques petits bruits
sur les quatre heures qu'on aura ça
arrivera 4 5 fois
pourtant c'est pas censé être le cas le
dimanche
mais bon mais au moins il fait au moins
je ne meurs pas de show elle va gagner
avec les bleus ont quand même parce
qu'il n'a pas assez de temps et pas une
assez bonne connexion pour jouer tempo
mais on sent vanina en tactique qui peut
être qui peut être au dessus de
kosteniuk mais je donnerai comme un
avantage à la joueuse la plus âgée des
deux on va voir donc on est reparti dans
ce cavalier avec trois matches avec avec
ses 4 sauf que cette fois n'y a pas eu
de coups g4 le fou qui est resté ans et
8 et les noirs qui prépare peut-être un
b 5 à un moment donné suivi de fou
bessette
bon pour le moment c'est un petit match
sympa hein c'est un petit match
sympathique
jusqu'ici c'est un petit match
sympathique alors je vous met sur la
chaîne du tribute fait ça tout de suite
c'est un petit match sympathique avec
des partis avec des parties
intéressantes écouter pour le moment moi
j'aime bien ce que je suis c'est parce
que vous vous en pensez mais je trouve
que c'est un match c'est un match assez
agréable
ma foi ça match assez agréable à suivre
pour le moment et donc fou qui à droite
est le pion à 7 qui va tomber
on va voir comment
[Musique]
comment ça évolue attendez fallait que
je réussisse à mettre ça bien comme il
faut
du coup il faut que je change ça comme
si le h3 la dame mais la dame 6 4 qui
est menacée
voir comment elle bouge si elle fait
dame prend à eux deux il ya peut-être
cavalli bref ces trois pour gagner
développement on va voir on va voir on
va voir comment ça évolue
peut-être qu alice ces trois joueurs
pour attaquer la dame mais bon les noirs
qui ont quand même pris trois pions
c'est pas négligeable trois pions c'est
quand même c'est quand même beaucoup
ça c'est fait et c'est réussi mais
peut-être que ces trois mais bon trois
pions ça fait beaucoup mais enfermé la
dame ça semble impossible à elle peut
sortir par là il peut sortir par là tu
m'as dit qu'elle va partir en h5 plutôt
fou prend à cette donc on récupère un
pion on va peut-être réussir en
récupérer un deuxième mais ça va être
difficile d'en récupérer 3 pour vanina
près trois pions ça fait quand même
beaucoup 1 puisque même site en récupère
deux même site on récupère deux ça va
pas ça pas être assez quoi il va faire
jouer un peu sur cette dame qui pour le
moment
et encore un peu mal placé est ce
qu'elle va partir en g6 ou est-ce qu'à
leurs parents à cinq elle repart en a
cinq
c'est vrai que si elle a réussi à faire
fou elle veut faire c6 et e5 peut-être
c'est ce qu'elle fait c'est si ça lui a
joué 5 bonsoir paquito paquito film en
est fou aussi ci a réussi à faire ces
deux coups là c'est fini d'ailleurs j'en
profite pour vous demander comment et le
son j'ai pas encore j'ai pas encore fixé
le j'ai reçu les lémurs à coller les
machins acoustique ce soit impeccable
des pâquis toi fm pacte au film en
salles à fond qui flex donc tour 8
protège le fou donc libère le cavalier
quelque part mais vraiment 5-fu aussi si
tu le fais c'est vraiment d'option net
après 1 elle est à deux coups avec les
noirs d'avoir une position complètement
écrasante cavaliers de j'aimerais bien
faire autre 5la j'empêche les arrivées
du cavalier jamais de fourrure 6 ça me
parait ça me paraît extrêmement fort
après ça fait le seul pouvoir il ya
l'embarras du choix ici pour pour les
noirs et c'est vrai que kosteniuk eux
alors le fait qu'elle soit plus forte
suisse smi surpris mais mais vraiment
semi on va dire
smith me
au café de damas ils saluent vraiment
conserver une pure oui parce que j'ai
oublié de dire c'est que sur 5 d'un
français 4 folie 6 c'est vrai qu'on a on
n'est plus le fou en prison pour rand
est un pion il en reste avec un clou de
plus c'est une position à très bonnes et
stricte dame insiste celle approche un
peu maximaliste
elle veut faire de 5 est fou et 6 donc
les blancs doivent ici trouver un coup
pour gêner car et f4 et sur cinq c'est
quoi l'idée cavaler âge sont amicales
sans qu'on va prendre auquel se planquer
des sacs faut prendre cette audacieuse 5
était jouable ou pas écart alliage 5 à
la fin ils menacent d'abattre à une
menace est fou prend qui on prend
mesdames et 5 donc f6 anticipe et la
veille avec les blancs ya juste pas de
jeu hein y'a juste pas de jeu là je vois
pas comment les blancs créé des menaces
fouet faryab et cinq fois failli à b5
donc bien qu'il ya un vrai problème
l'abbé 5 1 elle protège le pion à quatre
pieds
et d'amd 6 l/100 prompte à f2 et elle
prépare peut-être tour à sept pour
doubler sur la colonne a éclos le pion à
4 malaya vrai mal à garder les deux
pions et les blancs aux héros activités
c'est vraiment il n'ya même pas de moyen
de 2 crée une menace ni dans le chat de
temps tg5
ouais pourquoi pas pourquoi pas tenter
g5 g5 peut-être pas mauvais en tout cas
c'est une idée dames c'est de jouer
alors est-ce qu'elle va jouer le 5
maintenant est fou aussi ce look est ce
possible
possible le 5-fu aussi ce possible elle
fait tour à 7
donc elle veut gagner le plus haut à 4
60 où les coûts là qu'on voit ce sont
des coups à chaque fois il ya l'embarras
du choix
c'est difficile de s'en rend même
qu'elle est mieux et peut-être kébé cap
et avait pas de rebond des trois donc
c'est pour ça que c'est par bouger est
proposé mais pour eux à 7
tu t'en prends pion à 4 et tu veux
mettre la pression sur la torah ça me
parait ça me paraît somme toute très bon
très bien joué de la part des noirs qui
ont vraiment une position écrasante
vanina qui rien à faire auquel fébé
droit et au pire à la reprise prise et
on reprend 1,4 pour prendre un troisième
pion est une nouvelle fois il va falloir
30 et de pêcher en eaux troubles pour
pour vanina mais bon qu'est ce qu'y
at-il à pêcher les amis y'a vraiment pas
grand-chose à pêcher ici et là c'est
quand même c'est la catastrophe ada les
amis
c'est la catastrophe à la pour vanina
qui a une position complètement
complètement foutu bref c'est vraiment
c'est vraiment l'aurora da vient
absolument absolument absolument rien à
faire si ce n'est abandonné fou des
droits et damas est très près par tour à
deux peut-être pour attaquer de f2 et
les blancs qui ont toujours pas une
menace
foubert elle défend alors attention faut
pas bouger le cavalier ici allez vous
êtes un coup difficile à jouer pour les
noirs peut-être tour des quatre vingt
paquets et des cats surtout elle a fait
chez sis dont qu'elle chasse ce cavale
qui va devoir repartir en droit dans
quel point m6 tf6 qu'est ce qu'elle
tente tout retour avec cet échec à ou
qu'elle récupère le fou ouais mais alors
ça va pas bien loin je pense
il ya le roi qui va partir en fait
plutôt partie en g7 sans vraiment savoir
pourquoi ou en moins et vii ça va aussi
chez les parents pourquoi je préférais
l'autre case pour france et 8
elle va peut-être faire un bon c'est
vrai qu'à la fnac et c'est un grand mot
mais elle a obtenu plus de jeu qu'elle
n'aurait dû en avoir même si c'est
vraiment pas grand chose à mes a créé
peut-être un micro danger par les thèmes
des deux ici pour place éventuellement
un tour en f4 aura à contrôler vos coups
case les blancs n'ont pas la moindre
menace ici notre posture un retour à un
jouable aussi mais truc c'est que le fou
avons sales cloud elle fait autour des 4
mai aps a pas grand chose de plus tour
d'un échec
là il va voir d'amd saddam des singles
apprend des 5 et prend des cinq tours 37
ah ah ah oui mais je prends ici est sûre
on prend tout reprendra exactement bien
joué bien calculer il ya le foot est un
qui reste en prise avec les trois points
parce ailier de l'autre côté et donc ça
fait 3 1 pour pour alexandra honnêtement
alexandra qui domine largement le match
c'est la 1e position dans laquelle c'est
la femme part tout allait mieux
troisième victoire elle vendanges pas et
là on va avoir une petite va avoir le
droit à une petite finale de la
berlinoise les amis et une grosse
domination de kosteniuk pour lancer un
beau match un sérieusement
c'est vraiment un beau match pour le
moment entre les deux joueuses et qui
est des tas de têtes a six pour jouer
ces cinq cavaliers n 5 elle revient
salua le lapin rouge âgé cavaliers deux
peut-être un truc comme au café regarde
ce que les noirs ont tous dû rendre au
caire il l'a fait roi des halles a fait
voir des huits 3,8 donc un truc comme
bruxelles convoqué juste illégal
c'est important de bien se rappeler
qu'on n'a pas le roi troqué parce que
sinon ça peut vous faire faire un dépôt
illégaux et 2 vous pouvez vous mettre à
mal jouer et donc du coup peut-être
foule six tours des 8 mais le problème
c'est qu'en fait quand fois aussi s'il
peut y avoir des g4 f4f 4g 4 f 5
ça peut aller vite donc elle va mettre
le foin bessette et peut-être fait
retour des 8 pour déjà échangé une tour
quand même
karine f4 j'ai l'impression que ça se
passe assez bien pour les dons harris et
c5 et peut-être même une option avec
l'idée de mettre le cavalier en d4
bon c'est une bonne nouvelle cette
partie pour pour vanina hockey caïds et
4,6 comment tu défendes pions ses deux
oreilles pour senio qui fut une très
mauvaise partie là qui est procédant
imparable au prochain alors été des six
échecs ça j'ai envie de dire ça un peu
opportuniste et peut-être que ça pas ça
je pense fort à croire 17 il prend
bessette et prend ses deux tours d un
point à ses six tours b1 et roy prend 17
attention après un cavalier à cinq
échecs à un moment donné bon j'imagine
que les blancs doivent prendre 17 je
vois pas trop d'options sur quoi les
noirs pourront faire cavalier france et
2 elle prend f7
alors l'idée c'est d'aller prendre la
fuite parce que sur quelques français
doit le faire tour d un échec suivi
suivant ce qui se passe au pied prend la
fuite ou machin bull ok intéressant
intéressant qui est prend ces deux
opportunistes kosteniuk là dessus parti
très tactique
il ya achuthan prise il ya peu un ces
emprises elle fait aussi ses
intermédiaires
on imagine le roi partir ans et si sûr
que c'est 5,5 à roye b 5 et le roi hier
à se cacher n'y a pas de coups de casque
blanche donc ses moyens dangereux roi
c'est 8 ce sera un peu bizarre dans le
sens où la tour protégerait plus à
schwyz du coup alors je sais pas si ça
change grand chose mais elle part ans et
8 elle se garde le fou ouvert sans
répéter mon premier réflexe quand elle
prend à schwyz
il va y avoir prise en a prises ou
d'ailleurs
prises ont eu un le cavaly qui revient
et la tour tu l'aimés ou tu la mets en
d1 peut-être avec l'idée de faire tour
j'aime beaucoup la position des blancs
une nouvelle fois parce que le roi en
fait la même avec laurence et si ça
aurait été clairement mieux après je
sais pas si c'était possible ou pas
possible de façon sûre et quatrième sets
le retour mais j'ai l'impression que
laurence et 8 il empêche complètement de
de jouer la tour pour l'instant alors
poussé si c'est très bien joué et je
veux poser la question est ce que
cavaliers des cinq est une option
pendant qu'on discutait de sa et de rien
c'est fou prend g73 bessette et
cavaliers f7 alors maintenant peut-être
cavaliers 5 qui va arriver par la suite
mais matériellement on en est où zack
important de comprendre les blancs qui
ont un pion de plus et les noirs qui ont
la paire de fouet une pseudo attaque sur
g2 mais qui marche pas donc s'il est
blanc il s'affaire g3 f4 f5 m6 c'est
philippe fargo il faut qu'il se libère
le pion f6 le pion à f avance ce sera
fini après la difficulté des noirs ceux
des plans pardon c'est que les pièces
blanches sont pas forcément très bien
coordonnées
mais les noirs je vois pas trop comment
ils en tirent profit donc fait kébé 4l
un stade qui prend à deux ce qui
pourrait l'aider à avancer les pions
puis on avance peut-être caïds et 5
maintenant à quel dessein qui a chuté et
prend pardon donc cavalier à deux
menaces cavaillé prend à 3 et maintenant
est ce que les blancs peuvent faire je
rêve trop g3 données pions jouer
cavalier des 5es et préparer avec 4 5 et
6 donc ça ce serait dans l'idée de dire
ok je perds pas de temps à défendre mes
pions et je pars faire mine dame elle
fait à 4 écouter savent pas forcément à
grand-chose de prendre des risques et
donc elle fait à 4 elle empêche un peu p
et elle elle entre guillemets on
continue à regarder sous le sou
ou de l'avancée du pion f vanina qui est
de nouveau très mal autant ludique se
demande s'il faut f3 une option ouais
mais ça sert à quoi en fait
ok au cas où ça empêche les options
avancées
pourquoi pas mais sinon mise à part
attaqué une tour
enfin ces genres caisse et j'ai vu une
menace village où il n'y a pas de
profondeur
c'est juste parce que tu as vu un
clouage et que tu veux du coup le faire
mais ça ça a pas de ça fait pas plus que
menacé une tour en main rsa laisser tour
17 exactement série mais si tu veux
c'était pas le pouf f3c coup de coude
amateurs ça donc travailler à 6 et
maintenant quelle idée cinq exactement
ce qu'on avait prévu
pourquoi cavaliers des simples parce
qu'on veut tout simplement libéré le
pion f4 f5 apsys ce dont parlait et une
fois que le pion à elf arrive et qui
adoption passé lié c'est fini ah il
semble que kosteniuk en réalité soit
beaucoup plus forte que son adversaire
je la mettais pas aussi forte alexandra
même et elle me paraît il me paraît bien
au dessus des dont 4,5 qui va arriver
alors l'escale va jouer tout de suite ou
pas ça après avoir un elfe et cavaliers
wako c'est lui qui était champion du
monde mais après vanina qui est une très
forte devenant rapide donc on aurait pu
se dire qu'elle était peut-être même pas
renfort voire même plus forte en rapide
mais pour le moment kosteniuk ce qui est
impressionnant c'est qu'elle domine à la
position et comme vous le voyez à la
toujours de l'avant ce autant et c'est
ça qui est vraiment inquiétant pour pour
vanina sait qu'elle est dominée et à la
position et à la pendule et donc quand
tu qu'au cumul c'est de domination c'est
pas très très bon signe pour la suite du
match avec 16 secondes que c'est qui va
être la tour en voyait même ton 17
ici ça me rase tracas et des six échecs
au passage et sa prépa recettes donc
tour 17 ici paraît pas être un point
intéressant surtout ses six accueils des
huit voitures 17 sa part est vraiment
fort ici et c'est vraiment vraiment un
beau match de l'appart kosteniuk way
série qui nous dit que la victoire de
vanina dans la première c'est l'arbre
qui cache la forêt tout à fait un
elle a gagné la première partie est là
cavalier des six quais pour 4 et ses
pièces de plus ces quelques points 8 mai
- il ya tout qui emprise et ça fait 4 1
et là ça commence à faire cher les mecs
là ça commence à faire cher pour vanina
parce que je dirais que quand tu rentres
dans l'est dans les trois quatre points
de moins la tue disons qu'en tant que tu
as 1,2 point tu dis un petit rush
j'organise gens gagnent deux mais trois
points ça commence à être la zone où il
est difficile de revenir à lens on est
obligé de revenir de manière un peu tu
en gagnes deux temps par une pour gagner
d'autant par une un peu graduelle des
lampes plus ça fait 4 4 victoires
d'affilée pour pour vannes il a donc qui
joue au genre de version spec boleslav
ce qui je pense
avec le 3e des 5 mai qui est un genre de
tchekhov écossais new bike ya vraiment
un cas vraiment une belle avance et elle
a réussi à faire des cinq en force
donc je sais pas s'ils ont su encore la
théorie mais normalement quand tu fais
tes 5 dans cette structure de pions un
sas et structures de pions quant à eux 4
contre des six dessins qu'ils essayent
tout et t5 qu'elle a elle réussi à le
faire et en plus elle s'en prend au fond
donc peut-être les banques doivent déjà
essayer d'aller chercher la position y
apprend des cinq dames prend des 5
mais les blancs qui n'ont rien obtenu et
tous rêvent des 8es la position qui est
complètement égal voire même peut-être
plus simple à jouer pour les noirs
peut-être un petit plus pour les noirs à
la sortie de l'ouverture ça commence à
faire ça commence à faire lourd pour
pour vanina que je voyais plus forte
après valentine associe une joueuse de
roche c'est de jouer ce qui a besoin
d'être en forme pour bien jouer il ya
des jours elle joue très bien il ya des
jours où à tout - moins bien que
d'autres et elle est peut-être dans un
jour sans tout simplement la joueuse la
joueuse russe possible à une petite
erreur n'ont pas eu d abord je regardais
si tout était bien mais s'il ya une
erreur là il s'est passé un truc voyait
la fef si c'est tout reprend des 5
pouces écartés tour d un exactement ce
qui est en train de jeter un oeil sur
tout et était tout était bon en termes
de stream c'est le cas et il ya eu la
gaffe il ya eu cette grosse gaffe qui
qui va redonner un point vanina qui va
recoller un petit peu au score mais
c'est un peu par ailleurs par chance mes
réussites la sg 4 surgissent ici à
fouquereuil fils échec
elle va faire foudre ou fou et le site
peut-être même et elle va réussir à
aller gratter plus haut 4 et ça va
gagner mais très très étonnant
cette erreur de kosteniuk c'est vraiment
une grosse faute
on l'avait tous petits cailloux francky
et prend elle peut prendre un set
prendre 17
ça fait quoi il ya trois mois elle joue
la même c'est peut-être un petit peu
abusé parce qu'il ya une pièce c'est
inception moins bon tu peux vouloir
arnaquer mais un certain moment donné tu
dois quand même connaître tes propres
limites
c'est quand même un peu un peu beaucoup
quand même pas ce qu'est une pièce de
moins net a remis une pièce un peu moins
net en finale c'est quand même un peu un
peu spécial de jouer ça elle forçait un
petit peu et vanina qui recolle un peu
au score et qui revient à deux points et
on retourne dans cette karo kann alors
est-ce qu'elle va régler ses problèmes
où elle va rejouer jesse sinon il faut
qu'elle prenne en d5 avec le cavalier la
voilà
elle s'est rappelée est la une près par
là dessus c'est sûr et voilà j'ai six
maintenant
donc ça c'est plus proche de la vérité
foulée 5 saddam à quatre cavaliers b6
les deux joueuses qui ont l'air de
connaître ce qu'elles font mais ça va
rentrer dans des positions ça
complètement jouable
ok c'est marin ce qu'elle fait je pense
qu'elle veut apprendre et faire du x 10
6 peut-être pas direct cette fois 6 mais
maintenant la structure de pury option
isolé de ce côté-là pions isolé en c6
donc chacun sont plus isolés mais à
savoir lequel des deux plus faibles
f- f5 donc elle laisse fouache 6 elle se
laisse échangé le fou parce qu'elle
aurait pu faire tout rue89 ou d'avant et
sur x 6 x fois je suis tu es peut-être
avais pas envie de se prendre un truc et
kg 5
qui de toute façon semble arriver là les
blancs ils veulent kg 5 suivi de fou
prend g7 étant proches c'est alors
qu'est ce qui se passe sur kg 5 ici at a
time
je sais pas été peut-être soif si ce
soit autre chose pendant que ça échange
ça échange ça échange élargi et price 1
qui va reprendre 2g et la position qui
semble assez équilibré puisque d'un côté
il ya ces six de l'autre côté à des
quatre peut-être tour des huit onces et
peut-être c'est ok peut-être à voir ce
que tour des cistes peut-être jouable
aussi pour protéger le pion et après
m'être la tour ronde et 8 auxquels fait
tour ses huit protège le pion tout
pareil pour ces deux et peut-être été
des cinq bras voir
c'est bizarre mais en fait le cavalier
blanc eux deux est tellement bien placé
et vont peut-être cavaliers e71 est
jouable j'en rêvais en b3 et peut-être
on peut faire des radios 7 pour blinder
le pion on va voir ce que t'as pas envie
de donner ses six donc la tête jusqu'à
value est affecté et b4 dédain ou
qu'elle s'en est pris à a2 juste falloir
faire gaffe à troyes b 4 qui arrive pour
fixer le furet protéger le pion b
ok comment est-ce que ont réussi à
protéger sa faiblesse avec les noirs
tout en attaque tout en attaquant des 4
propose de 5,5 c'est un coup un coup
candidats après je l'aurais jamais joué
j'épargne kacou comme tours 6 jab son
camp je veux cinq que je m' a faibli
mais mec mais puis on doublait donc j'ai
pas envie de m'affirmer mais qu'il
aimerait bien réussir un progresser sans
fard cinq ans ça peut peut-être est par
tour des six tours des cinq tours ces
quatre peut-être
or elle fait avec 4 elle empêche et elle
prépare wave ii roi ou trois clairement
mais la grosse question c'est qu'est ce
qui se passe sur a3 ici cavalia six
tours france et 6 lancer de vraies
questions à 3 ici ouais c'est jouer et
vanina qui perd le pion très bêtement
donc c'est une grosse erreur tactique
une nouvelle fois et ça repart dans le
bordel parce que les noirs ont quand
même beaucoup d'activité mais je pense
pas qu'ils avaient vu aussi loin
honnêtement parce que ça peut paraître
dangereux de donner du matériel comme ça
kerry c3 qui est prend des deux est sûre
cavaliers prendre des 5,5 et pour les
trois équipes et la suisse qui est
prendre cinq points qui les prend des
deux et les noirs qui veulent tout
reprend des cas d'un ténor qui ont
complètement retourné la situation et
qui se retrouve maintenant même assez
bien peut-être puisque ya le pion des
cartes qui peut tomber qu'elle va
prendre des quatre atouts requis dans
ses sept tours 17 tomber cette prise
prise donc là il ya ce pion qui est
menacée
voyez déjà une école cdi cde est tout
retourné trois genre de truc comme ça
auxquels fait tomber un mythe auquel
veut jouer pour tours b3 et si la tour
violences et entrave pour prendre pour
prendre un cavalier deux échecs au quai
ouest ce qui veut dire que tomber 3 soit
vous sera vraiment fort donc pour baby
très bien joué laguna qui peut à mon
avis rockall au score et revenir à un
point d'eux kosteniuk et la finale ce
sera le 27 ans les mecs grande finale le
27 à partir de 18h même heure même
endroit
tour 17
alors
à ses côtés sur la meilleure case
possible et sur tourbe et 3 pour prendre
un tour à tour à 4 qui sera très pénible
et la tour pour aller assister ce sera
probablement une nulle théorique
donc c'est pas vraiment optimale au kéké
cécile idée m est obligé de faire avec a
été quatre fers et tours 17
et ça réfère nul belle défense de la
part de kosteniuk qui réussit parce que
le 26 ans et qui pour montrer le chien
qu'on a vu inscrivent l'autre jour
j'espère le chien
j'espère le chien alors oui nice a
réussi à tirer ça nul cette fois ci qui
a réglé ses problèmes dans la carro
cannes et qui parlera maintenant pour
une web grâce à transposer dans une
grande bitam et même dans une catalane
donc dans une catalane tourbe et vite
c'est la même position que tout à
l'heure les noirs qui s'était retrouvé
que 3 points de plus si vous vous
rappelez bien et cette fois ci le pion
des quatre qui est blindé donc les
blancs qui vont pas avoir trois points
trois pions de moins dans celle là donc
il faut prendre cette reprise set
peut-être à me2 et du jouable lors du
raz b 5
c'est là qu'on voit tout l'intérêt du
coup tombée 8 en fait c'est qu'on
protège le pion b et le roi et paella la
tour est plus dans la diagonale du fou
donc elle fait à 4 probablement à 6 mais
peut-être à 5 même qu'ils s'arriment pas
trop mal fait rock c'est vrai que ok
mesdames c'est demain elle peut plus
faire un site bessac
et sur qui revenait à 5 à cavani d2 on
va récupérer le pion c4 en douceur bon
je vois pas comment ok mais elle veut
peut-être faire fou 17 qui prend ses
quatre epr en s'écartant français qu'à
tfou c6 ou alors jouer c'est simple
question prend ses 5 et dames c'est
cette équipe français catalan français 5
du coup les noirs et les blancs qui
pensent pareil chez synck menace
matt cavalli revient angers 6 pour
défendre et maintenant les blancs
peut-être un bon coup ils font cavalier
e 4 donc ils s'accrochent aux pions c5
et ils préparent ils préparent pied
france et 4 en fait tout bêtement f5
jouer qui est des sites d'armes français
est-ce que ça a vraiment un intérêt
d'être allé [ __ ] les cavaliers en d6
auquel reprend ce cavagnan c4as provoque
un petit peu l'idée de faire re 5 avec
les noirs un pur jeu quatre peut-être
est enfermé le fou donc pris ses 4 une
première fois
la logique voudrait qu'on prenne de la
dame
pour plein pour pour ceux des clous et
en fait tout bêtement mais vont prendre
du carrier a peut-être d'autres
avantages garder les dames sur
l'échiquier tête 7 d'avancé 5 peut être
un peu vulnérable à voir en tout cas
qu'il prend ses 4 est une option ici
qu'elle fait d'armes français 4 c'est le
coup qu'on avait vu en premier constat
qu calais prend sekkat est aussi
possible des six a aidé c'est que
surprise prise elle veut jouer sur la
colonne ouverte
après on pourra jouer b3 tour à deux
tours ces deux tours c'est un et mettre
la pression sur le pion c5
écoutez position pas clair vanina qui
recolle un peu là depuis depuis qu'elle
a gagné la partie sur la gaffe de
kosteniuk c'est un peu comme si que
c'est mieux qu'avant un poil baissé le
pied
je ne sais pas ce que vous en pensez
dans le chat les amis mais j'ai
l'impression kosteniuk à un poil baissé
le pied et vanina est en train de d'en
profiter pour recoller faut aussi faire
begag direct mais peut-être que tu veux
que tu veux plutôt plus d'autres tenir
le truc tranquille donc à fait dans le
détroit
il est de retour c'est un tour b un tour
d un pardon mais mais il semble il
semble qu'elle soit qu'elles soient pas
mal dans la partie gwennyn a en tout cas
elle a eu un début de match fut
abandonnée là quand elle a perdu les
quatre les quatre parties d'affilée
il ya eu un coup très dur pour elle
hélas il semble petit à petit que ça
revient alors à un peu raté la partie
précédente aurait pu revenir à un point
mais en tout cas elle commence à voir
les positions
là on voit que la dame est bien placé
par rapport aux curieux 6 le carrier qui
revient en d4 qui masquait ses 6
elle est en train de faire elle en train
de faire le jeu là
joueuse j'ai envie de dire la joueuse
russe mais elles sont toutes les deux
russes mais en tout cas elle en train de
mieux faire elle est en train de revenir
dans le match et ça fait ça ne sonne
fait plaisir ça nous fait plaisir
puisque on veut avoir un match serré et
en plus nous comme elle joue avec nous
en pro de celle ci que ça fait plaisir
aussi à la sir a réussi à l'emporter 1
forcément est un peu cette histoire de
voir on a joué avec elle en équipe et
tout ça donc forcément il ya le côté un
peu un peu partisan de tours c'est à
elle veut rentrer éventuellement sur la
septième rangée par tour c'est cette
donc pas mal affectés en c6 attentive et
en baissse est allé là faudrait trouver
quelque chose maintenant il ya peut-être
un truc à jouer pour les blancs autour
des 1 tour 17
tout reprendre
on va voir et pour un set quand même
joie mais avoue prend 1,4 d'un pro b 6
ok ça va faire un pion cette histoire là
les mecs donc
kosteniuk qui envoie f4 elle envoie f4
d'apprendre mais si c'est sûr tu en
prends j'ai trois filles on prend g3 et
surtout on prend aux trois dames prend
1,3 qui viendra couvrir
donc j'imagine pour kosteniuk il faut
vraiment prendre le pion à quatre ans
parce que le quart nuls elle est mal
placée parce que ils seront une focale
alors la menace si on prend j'ai trois
pions projet 3d prend un f2 donc elle
crée une menace
donc si on prend effet à jouer qui ont
pas être 4 et l'a sûrement à 5 et sur
pions préemption prend la dame des six
qui intervient donc c'est très bien joué
de la part de de vanina cavaliers 2,5
donc là ça va jouer que pour la remarque
un côté noir mais ces deux jeux ans et
du blitz il va falloir défendre et s'est
fait de la veille dame des quatre alors
sur qui on prend peut-être dame prend
1,5 d'un problème de roy h1 et on ignore
on ignore complètement paraître
d'apprendre apprend et ça paraissait
bien nom d'emprunt f2 roi h1 j'ai
peut-être raté quelque chose mais
c'était peut-être comestibles parce que
là le phare faire gaffe parce qu'après
il faut prend dame prend ya x 3 qui rôde
et sur d'un prend 17 dame preuve de ça
me fait plus peur qu'au précédent
à force de ne pas vouloir prendre de
risques qu'un parfois en vain parce que
ça me prend 2,5 est ce que ça va juste
être le petit coup d'ordi pourtant si ça
marchait est-ce que là on pouvait faire
dame prend 1,5
non il y avait gprenc de roy h un fou g4
ouais donc ça marchait pas et ça
marchait pas
le problème c'est le cas va y en a 7 ans
qui participe à nous tous au jeu et le
roi blanc qui a un plan en danger donc
peut-être qu'à 5 c'était un peu
dangereux finalement allé faut
absolument ramener ce cavalier meilleur
foie jeu 3-1 qui menaça menacera dame
afin d'amuser de maths
roy qui est mieux ici en fait peut-être
dame e3 d'amener un roi j'ai deux voire
trois g2 direct
mais moi j'ai deux directs a peut-être
au f5 fougue quatre tours c'est cet été
un échec
il ya peut-être du flash 3 ici qui
rôdent roy prendra machin 3g 4 attend
elle a joué sa tempo et kosteniuk et ce
qu'elle a vu jusqu au bout parce que
l'art watch quatre d'un machin hockey à
moins ce qu'ils aimaient mieux chats
sont rangés 5 et tour f 5 tours h5 maths
et larroy g4 force et puisque roy g5
quoique h6 roi g6 d'âme des uns parce
que surtout elle s'est peut-être dame
prend et et on pouvait jouer pour le
match donc ça à faire nul mais les x 3
way analyse super vite pour ça ils
devaient qu'elle a dû calculer et elle
retourne dans cette
elle retourne dans cette gare locale
alors je suis un petit peu enfin je suis
pas étonné étonné mais c'est vrai que
kosteniuk a montré de belles choses dans
le dans la dernière partie dans cette
carreaux cannes donc ok étonnant
qu'elles qu'elles retournent dedans
quand même boudina vanina là qui avait
qu'il y avait vraiment qui est vraiment
bien géré cette karo kann savait qu'il
fallait regarder la partie
gwennyn à lanfains quatre chefs ou nina
années vont quand tu baves là dedans une
variante forcément ça te place un peu au
dessus des autres donc menace le pion
aux cette menace ou n'est ce pas
d'ailleurs à nancy menace aussi c'est
toujours un peu tendu parce qu'un jour
tu peux te prendre des g4
il faut peut se retrouver enfermé donc
là il faut il a fallu quelques fous g5l
fait apsys donc et surtout à 6h et 5
avec un minimum à 1 perpète si elle veut
garder les fous et s'ils font reculer
peut-être g5 quand même est fou g6 qui
va à venir ok donc c'est bien joué aussi
savent si cela très bien joué je trouve
de la part de vanina ouais ça donne 2,4
c cardère moi je la joue aussi avec les
blancs et ses blagues qui me l'avait
recommandé un c'est pas une mauvaise
variante si les gens connaissent pas
tout donc j'ai cinq dames j'ai 3 h 5
donc ça c'était du compris et vu là sa
menace h4 qui forcerait kiev en h4
on imagine h4 mais j'ai quatre quelques
avanies devrait bouger on pourra faire
dame prend des 4 c'est intéressant là la
manière de jouer de vanina là encore je
trouve que c'est une bonne partie
personnellement et on voit vanina qui
qui a fait cette prise d' espaces devant
son propre droit parce que y'a mission
qu eto o kleiber g4 analyse ses écrits
vendus dans du papier de velours et sur
cavaliers age ii d'apprendre et 4 voilà
le pion qui tombe et là c'est qu'à 20
pions plus et c'est un pion central en
plus
allez les noirs qui peuvent jouer du tam
décathlon mettre le fion e5 fuji 6 7 5 à
4 c'est un peu le plan et non mais c'est
un gros pions plus et en plus c'est une
grosse prise d'espacé cavaliers h2k la
rue ça se passe très bien
ça se passe très bien pour vanina la
cavalier c4 est une option d'ailleurs
aussi peut-être sans prendre un peu au
fond ce soit il faut pas se retrouver
comme tout à l'heure la partie
précédente avec les pièces loin du jeu 5
et 6 4 pour faire un peu rentré ses
cavales en jeu mais maintenant il faut h
si ce qui est pénible dame prend b2 ll
va prendre le matériel tour et peut-être
forcé je pensais seul coup ici menace
matt tours fc 3 7 tours g8
foucher 4 alors menace vous prend 1,6
ici le quart a listé trois qu'un peu mal
mais a peut-être tour b1 maintenant
intermédiaire puis maintenant il ya plus
le foie f5 pour bien peut être un peu
intermédiaire intéressant pour un peu
demandé à peut-être d'amd de adapté de
pas possible il faut qu'ils reculent
donc ils tournent autour b1 forcerait
damas trois et j'ai l'impression que on
a plutôt envie de faire ça fout c'est un
alors là sur dame prend et avec
cavaliers de b3 j'imagine qu'ils
enfermer les dames des cas tempo mais je
suis pas fan des coups comme fou c'est
après c'est vrai que ça a le mérite de
garder le fou mais je suis pas fan dans
le sens où elle fouille va faire leur
bouger là on peut pas faire foudroyer
dame france et trois cavaliers attaqué
cavaliers pros de six caisses et hyper
tactique encore comme party tour huit
pieds qui étrangers 7
je suis quasiment sûr tu es noir quelque
chose ici mais je vois pas donc à
peut-être rien kosteniuk fidèle à son
style un toujours très tactique toujours
très tactique
c'est vrai que c'est par à jouer
cavalier u6 la sortie de nulle part
vraiment étonnant foussat cavaliers
progressiste à l'enchaînement c'est bien
peu comme une surprise que la devise us
a envie de dire il ya un truc qui gagne
et puis au final quoi les échecs c'est
un jeu qu'on crée fou progressiste ou
reprendre 6 et f5
mais sam n'a à sa menace d'armes
français 3 parce qu'après d'armes france
et 3 le flou sera plus que louer mais
les blancs qui peuvent le fou des deux
peut-être atouts des deux têtes dam des
quatre échecs ont peut-être jouable mais
mais le dam des quatre échecs et à
lecavalier qui arrivera en c4
ok donc c'est bien joué se f 5 qui crée
une menace et en cas d'un coup de
cavaliers manqué eux deux jouables
la tour est pas protégé mais peut-être
un coup comme moi je sais tu arriverais
et on a on n'a pas créé la tour et la
tour peut pas venir en b1 il ya des
dames ces cinq échecs de rebond qui
peuvent exister il ya des dames g4 donc
elle fait tout rejet 600 lits des
sections dame france et roi de france et
roi fou prend ces trois tant qu'étranger
le fou était cloué méroise 7 qui
renouvelle les menaces et là maintenant
il ya peut-être fou prend un c'est une
tour auquel vous prend d'aller g5 faut
calculer
date on pourra faire dames 1
à tout âge 6 matt aut les amis tous âges
six matches incroyables j'avais raté
aussi oh quelle arnaque au cal arnaque a
bien joué de la part de kosteniuk tout
racisme attend d'un os il était vicieux
suis là les mecs hausse est venue comme
une surprise incroyable incroyable tout
racisme at en a assez c'était joli ça
c'était joli attendez on va on va on va
retourner le voir
tant pis on pas on quitte le direct une
seconde je retourne je retourne vous
montrer sa main ce pourquoi pourquoi
est-ce que j'ai pas les parties
précédentes
mince mince mince j'ai fermé la partie
précédente et j'arrive pas ouais j'ai
pas j'ai pas les archives des autres
joueurs malheureusement
ouais c'est venu quel piège quel piège
parce qu'en fait
vanina fait la même erreur que moi serre
que tu calcules d'alger cinq dames eu un
fou et s'inquiète août la bonne compagne
et oublie le fou en c1 elle est vraiment
belle et piégeuse 7 7 7 kosteniuk à ces
arrivées vraiment comme comme une
surprise le matin l'a complètement
inattendu on était en train de calculer
des petites variantes
c'est vraiment joli c'est vraiment un
petit pas un piège
c'était une idée offensive de la part de
d'alexandra mais c'est vraiment
créativement le fou en c1 tu l'oubli
quoi incroyable bien joué très très bien
joué de la part d'alexandre a et on voit
vraiment je trouve que c'est très
révélateur de du danger conjuguées
contre kosteniuk moi qui ai eu
l'occasion de la rencontrer plein de
fois sur deux chaises comme quand
joue les arénas si tu réussis à l'année
sur un terrain plutôt stratégique des
finales des machins des petits systèmes
de londres city arrive des trucs très
calme ça va aller en fait parce qu'elle
va chercher les tactiques avait cherché
à attaquer ça peut bien se passer
t'inquiète pas ça va bien se passer bien
se passer ne t'inquiète pas mais quand
tu vas contre kosteniuk sur du terrain
ultra tactique etc à l'attack helm
arnaquer plus d'une fois l attaque très
bien il ya plein de trucs et elle est
vraiment très très forte elle est très
très très forte et la compa lentilles
être plus intéressant parce que
valentina elle joue aussi elle son jeu
et là on voit vraiment on voit vraiment
la force de kosteniuk qui a déjà battu
dans des tournois officiels hambli de
ceux des joueurs comme cramique donc
c'est pas n'importe quoi c'est pas de
ces pas de lola c'est sérieux comme
adversaire elle est allée très
dangereuse et elle a vraiment le fou 5
est revenu il n'y avait pas du tout
harmonie dans les pièces de alexandra
c'était très brouillon et tout d'un coup
sorti de nulle part elle elle elle ne se
refait de elle se refait de l'harmonie
elle est vraiment très doué c'est beau
c'est bon franchement c'est très joli
piège
elle reprend trois points non mais c'est
pas de l'ours et pas de l'eau donc vous
voyez de jeu et se concentrer mais ça va
être dur à mendier pour valentina qui a
quand même bien serré le jeu 1 depuis
qu'elle est menée 4-1 alors serré le jeu
mais il ya toujours plus 3 il ya
toujours plus trois pour pour kosteniuk
dans le contenu c'est mieux il ya
vraiment du mieux côté vanilla là une
bonne position mais elle peut payer ce
petit retard parce que ça va être dur de
jamais se faire arnaquer il va falloir
accepter les arnaques ça arrivera un
jour contre une joueuse redoutable et ça
va être dur de recoller il faut il
faudrait il reste combien de temps dans
le dans le cinq plus simple il reste six
minutes il reste peut-être de partir et
ça l'est peut-être une autre
hier écoutez je pense que c'est vraiment
important là pour eux pour vanina de pas
de parent ne pas baisser pavillon
alors n'y a pas un qui va libre en
bessin qui s'y donnent envie quand même
à première vue ce que tu gagnes un pur
avec tempo mais elle veut probablement
dame b 6 cavaliers des canons qu'elle
suit la première idée hein je n'ai pas
parlé ou quoi mais la première année
cette plante un cavalier f5 et une dame
en g7 et non notamment tu peut-être
cavaliers f5 et des 6 un monde aussi
pour attaquer le cavalier donc tous ces
cinq cas il prend p5 maintenant qu'il
faut nettement je pensais qu'elle ferait
cavalier 5 quand même et qu'elle
laisserait pions avec deux en se disant
j'ai mis mon cavalier ici et je vais
jouer pour le match je pensais qu'elle
enverrait comme ça parce que là ce que
j'aime pas trop dans les pièces blanches
c'est qu'il ya beaucoup de choses qui
sont attachées les unes aux autres
notamment les cavaliers et ça pourrait
mal se passer un moment donné à voir une
nouvelle fois ses positions assez
bordélique mais on sent que même si
vanina est très fort dans ses positions
là ça semble quand même ça semble quand
même favorisé la joueuse
la plus âgée des deux la championne du
monde donc fou et 4 as assez bien joué
elle veut faire dame f3 dame f5 dame
prend ou d'un f3 d'alger quatre échecs
crois je suis dame f5 et dames proche 7
mat
donc c'est malin f5 intermédiaire très
malin sur foot pro f 5 fu prend des cinq
qui vient contrôler la case f3 affaiblir
les cases blanches et ramener la dame
noire aussi qui peut maintenant
intervenir sur sur a6 j'aimerais
vraiment vous vous regardez ce coin f5
c'est vraiment très révélateur du talent
que c'est mieux qu'à l'ajout en 15
secondes et vous voyez opposition
déséquilibrée gros bordel sur
l'échiquier vraie menace blanche qui
veut menace vraiment de rentrer et f5
qui est un coup vraiment intéressant
puisqu'il vient offrir de l'harmonie
quand même au noir et la défense
cependant cavaliers pros f5 bien joué
puisque maintenant les blancs veulent
dame c3 et cavaliers h6 échec et mat
bon là il ya la dame qui protège
employeurs dame c3 et dames g7 maths et
ce avec dame ses trois sacres à une
vraie menace est fou prend un f2 une
nouvelle fois c'est pas grave a en fait
roi g2 et tant pis alors maintenant il
faut voir aussi d'apprendre des 5 1 qui
est un peu le coût principal est sûre
d'un prend p 5
c'est quoi le truc c'est peut-être d'un
f3 même plutôt avoir avoir ce cas pas de
made direct sur le pion qui vient m6 est
en fait un problème cinq dames f3 donc
c'est la partie on devine pas mal les
coups aujourd'hui et dames f3 c'est vrai
que c'est fort parce qu'elles menacent
d'alger quatre dames g7 est sûre dam des
six dames j'ai qu'adam g ici à cavalaire
h 6 échecs il faut projet 6 donc elle
commence par watt 8 dames h5
hélas le pion est vraiment dur à
défendre
il va vraiment falloir qu'elle sorte une
idée de son chapeau dame b 6
alors là je ferais bien qu'il y ait deux
des six avec les blancs
franchement avec l'idée d'un proche 7
mater cavaliers pro f 7 et de koupéla et
de couper un peu tout ce qui ce qui
regarde de ce côté là je pense vont
affecter idée this tout cas c'est le
premier coup j'aurais regardé pour
complètement couper le jeu adverse mais
qui a été si ça peut-être f5 des iapteff
cinq cavaliers 7,3 g7 qui a aidé 6ème 5
peut-être c'est ça le problème par le
problème c'est ça l'idée qu'elle et 6 7
5 et des six journées f5 va être joué
c'est le seul coût de toutes façons
défense pour il peut y avoir un problème
de intermédiaire mais je vois pas trop
l'intérêt
mais elle simple c'est assez joli ça
défend l5 bien jouer fou prend f5 et
maintenant tourcoing f5 âme et ont quand
même 5 à le faire dès 8 et karine et ben
c'est pas clair bond de 63 9 5 ya pas
d'autres coûts
après je vous garantis paquet pas un
gain pour pour les blancs qui est
peut-être qu'elle se demande c'est fou
pro f deux échecs en premier
fêtons point f 5 cavaliers pros f5 et
maintenant peut-être d'alger 6 et
maintenant peut-être dame g6 qui couvre
tout la lame sont obligés de repartir
vie à eux deux pour parfum non attendez
faut compter le matériel ici c'est les
blancs qui sont mieux matériellement
maintenant il beaucoup de bordel auquel
il n'est pas fou prend des havres prend
des 5% des 5 et prend des cinq prises
des 5 ça va ok c'est les blancs qui sont
gagnants ici mais faut encore la gagner
côté new qui a survécu l'attaquent jolie
partie très très jolie partie les amis
dame m6 c'est difficile d'évaluer çà et
là il prend des cinq tours e8 et tours 8
peut-être fou et fuite s'est joué c'est
la partie damages simple retour
peut-être ici ahmed hammache cinq gamins
ou attention attention vanina attention
vanina ay ay ay le maître du couloir a
assez encore une nouvelle fois tour huit
échecs
maxime qui voulait faire dame c3 mais ça
marche pas il ya dame france et trois
points est fille de flou g8
attention maxime j'ai envie de dire
attention maxime presque mais elle peut
y a de nouveau le matin c'est incroyable
pour eux huit échecs qui paraissait être
un bon coup et elle a de nouveau tendu
un piège
qu'est ce que c'est malin peut-être
faire damas trois du coup damas 3 d'un
point f5 d'un prend des quatre et on
couvrira la casse b1
ok peut-être damas trois est jouable ici
d'un bref cinq dames promet 4 et on
recouvre le mat jolie géométrie je sais
par un jeu lâche une info comme ça j'en
sais rien mais ok pris ce prix de la
sueur roi g8 n'ont aidé à me 5
oui alors c'est pas facile à jouer avec
les noirs quand même peu de temps sur la
pendule et ce avec le duo dame cavalli
est bon
6 j'adore ce coup stabilise mais
maintenant il va falloir résister quand
même cavalier être roi ici et qui est
prend des cinq maintenant acquis et
prend des cinq ça marche et non puis on
prend des cinq dames prend dé 5,2 me
prends des trois c'est peut-être un raté
hamel a réussi à récupérer la pièce
alameda bf3 oh ça fait mal vous surtout
pas échanger les dames ici risques et
prend des 5 ha oui ok alors excusez moi
autant pour moi autant pour moi mais
c'est vrai qu'il ya tellement d'arnac un
partout grâce et cette dame g7 alors
comment est ce qu'on essaye d'éviter les
échecs avec les noirs parce que c'est
vrai que c'est un monde il n'y a pas
d'échec qui aura d'alger de maths et les
blancs peuvent pas échanger les dames
ok roi des six damas trois mois ces cinq
donc à fait fou fou aussi ce que je
ferais bien ok bouge le roi peut-être
fouache trois belges ou des coûts et
maintenant faut envoyer deux pions avec
les blancs il va falloir envoyer le pion
à l'est vanina elle va tomber à elle est
tombée à ça fait plus 4 ol c'est mal
celle là c'est une partie c'est une
partie qui va compter c'est là les amis
c'est une partie qui va compter je crois
que c'était la dernière de la cadence ou
pas c'est pas ça dépend du lag peut-être
à la seconde près on a encore une
mais c'était une sacrée partie des amis
et qui fait très mal à vanina parce que
ça fait deux fois comme dirait femmes +4
6 6 au lieu de perdre les deux tu les
gagnes
il y aurait égalité au score mais les
deux fois c'est kosteniuk à ses côtés
nyuki au dessus quand même légèrement
elle est un peu plus forte dans le petit
jeu tactique et maxime qui sépare et
maxime qui sert barré après avoir vu le
dame c3 il a décidé
alors pensez leur milieu dame ses trois
essais non je pars le niveau de ce chat
est beaucoup trop puissant pour moi je
m'en vais quoi donc
vanina qui nierait qui va avoir du mal
causé new qui se fait quand même
remarquer j'ai juste pris ma retraite du
parc ont d'ailleurs maxime pour la
croatie ces cantons ton départ allait
vanina qui est derrière
vanina qui est derrière les mecs c'est
demain écoute en tout cas je me permets
de te souhaiter de la part de tous les
tontons un très bon tournoi en croatie
même si tu sais qu'on attend surtout à
moscou mais on te souhaite bonne chance
on suivra t parti et dans tous les cas
moi je ferai une vidéo fait j'ai un truc
c'est que je fais des vidéos à chaque
fois que tu gagnes que tu perds ou tu
joues contre magnus donc dans les trois
cas en fait je fais des vidéos donc on
ne se suivra à moscou rama moscou ifa à
yuma là j'arrive pas à me faire en fait
ces grands prix du coup deux premiers
cas à moscou est ce que tu as déjà
habitent c'est d'ailleurs un maxime
contre
contre alexandra kosteniuk parce qu'elle
peut être hyper dangereux je me rappelle
l'avoir vu au championnat du monde de
blitz à moscou justement là c'était
vraiment à moscou celui qui était dans
le groupe et je crois que c'est une
vérité qui était dans le groupe ou alors
à coup sûr google apps qui boulevard là
où l'autre mais en tout cas j'avais vu
blitz et elle était vraiment très forte
en fait elle tenait tête fin - elle a
probablement fini dernière parce qu'elle
était genre habitants wild card
mais elle n'était pas ridicule quoi tu
voyais les partis même contre les cram
nique et compagnie elle enfin vraiment
elle jouer tu vois enfin ça faisait se
faisait pas j'aurai écrasé à l'ami des
points et plein de partie très tendue et
de mémoire je les ai vus battre cramique
mais je sais plus si c'est en partie
officielle ou si c'était un blitz amical
entre elles jouent bien dial a fait
reprendre son coût à magnus
je connais pas le jeu connaît pas
l'histoire
l'anecdote max mais en tout cas elle
était elle était vraiment pas ridicule
quoi tu te serais hibon way à 3 200 300
points elo d'écart machin en fait elle
vise vraiment bien
connais tu as mis 5 0 qui avait à lapins
voulu de riz match mais ça date un peu
mais bon après si j'étais en forme elle
pas en forme ça peut aller vite quoi mes
mails n'habitera ont pas mal avait fait
une vidéo youtube il faut que je faut
que je trouve ça la pls pour pour magnus
faut que je trouve ça l avait battu vlad
d'ailleurs dans ce tournoi de blitz mais
vlad qui était peut-être pas au meilleur
de sa forme
mais quand même elle avait battu
et tu vas jamais joué en bis ouais bah
écoute aller d'enjeu si jamais tu la
joues un jour fait gaffe parce qu'elle
est dangereuse comme faut faire gaffe
et là on le voit bien dans le match dans
les tactiques et où elle elle est
redoutable
elle parle français
j'imagine oui puisqu'elle elle vit en
tout cas l'a vécu à paris là qui est
endormi sur l'échiquier plus ou moins
plate qui était plus ou moins endormi
sur l'échiquier ce jour là à temps y'a
pas qui a et b 6 ans fermes la dame pas
tant qu'amis et à des castes pour la
dame c'est moi qui hallucine parce que
du coup puis on prend rage est un pion
prend roi prend tant qu'amis isalva où
la dame attend c'est moi qui hallucine
jeu mais je mets leur vie parce que hay
adams et 5 par don lam c 50 hockey c5
j'hallucine j'ai du mal à parler avec le
chat et regarder la partie en même temps
incendiaires de caudry merci à max ok
donc bien joué de la part de vanina qui
peut faire à g kg 5 par la suite attaqué
du coup est ce qu'avec les blancs on
peut réfléchir agecale pour fermer il
faudra faire garde peut arriver des fous
g5 faut être quatre kg 5 ça peut rentrer
sur les cases noires c'est toujours un
dilemme cornélien et j'ai 4 h30 ici avec
du g3 kg 5e 3 probablement donc à fait
qu'ils aient baissé si on prend du coup
peut-être au caire on apprend ça fait
quand même hyper peur ok je jouais
remarque fou h katia rien reprend h4 et
et quoique dame franges et 2 commencent
à y à rien et dames pranger 2 et dames
pranger 2 les amis et à me plonger 2
donc mais on peut faire éventuellement
rouages de dames ces cinq échanges et
revenir et l'orangé 1 on va se retrouver
mal il y aura foule prend f2 à la fin
peut-être même fou prend un fief de
direct peut-être qu'il prend des 5 kg 5
d'un match 3 qui est proche 3 comprend h
trois tours prend des 5 et wes hayatou
qui va tomber à elles font preuve de sa
regagné bien joué et s'éprend des
sahraouis s'éprend des cinq encore plus
fort effectivement maxime tg5
ça et c'est dévoiler encore plus fort
voilà fekkai âge 3 au 6 mai jolie partie
une nouvelle fois et vous prendre au
quai dans ce temps là mais bon ça gagne
quand même non ouais ça gagne quand même
ça gagne quand même très bien joué de la
part de vanina partie de malades c'est
vraiment un beau match au sérieux maxime
je sais pas ce que tu en penses la
chebba pour toi tu as vu de ton niveau
de jeu ce que ça donne mais sérieux
c'est des partis qui sont en tout cas
pour les amateurs que nous sommes
vraiment des partis assez spectaculaire
c'est vraiment joli
au début c'était pas ou fait
effectivement mais la sérieuse ça s'est
un peu franchement ça c'est bien mais
non c'est là ça fait vraiment des belles
games banques et là on peut peut-être
faire un truc sommes ok je sais pas si
je me serais j'aurais fait fouet deux
mais peut-être tour des uns est ce que
c'est vrai aussi intéressant que ça
aurait fait flasher 4e set qui a eu 4 ou
7 et puis après tu loues peut-être même
pas foule ce est en fête qui avait lieu
4 et puis tu tu te places au cachet
fawcett était tour h4 tourage suite
maintenant paris-tours h4 je renvoyais
rights watch quatre se fait plaisir à
bien jouer bien joué
peut-être tout rage suite après food et
mitsou p6 comme ça en attaque de partout
est rare au cas où on reviendra avec la
tour en des huit j'aurais fait ça
j'aurais fait toujours la food & me
trouver 6 probablement ses 5 avait bien
joué maximum ok mais attend puis on
prend ces cinq tours prend le 4.4 pour
montrer l'idée tour des deux échecs
gagne le fou plus précis de la part de
vanina mais bon là la position qu'elle
était pion de plus c'est vrai que
c'était assez assez tranquille et donc
ça va être bien
enfin ça est bien pour vanina qu'il va
recoller à trois points à la fin du 5 +
1 et ben je suis plus confiant que quand
il y avait trois points d'écart un peu
plus tôt dans le match vanina qu'il ya
un poil accéléré et c'est vrai que ça
fait la différence mais on voit
kosteniuk qui essaye tout le temps de
même quand elle est perdante même temps
c'est fini a laissé tout le temps de
rester dans la partie
c'est pas évident et l'a peut-être
décider 3d 2 elle envoie le pion des et
là ils menacent marc andré roy j'ai
trois tours prend le 4.4 et des deux
donc avec et peut-être trouvé qu'à toi
là ça va rentrer tout seul vous prend
des 2 tours 4
et c'est gagné et vanina qui recolle à 3
points
le match tient toutes ses promesses les
tontons n'hésitez pas à mettre des
petits liens sur les réseaux sociaux
parce qu'on suit n'a vraiment à un match
de qualité alors là il nous met 7 3
milliards bien 7 4 1 le score n'est pas
juste le score qu'on a à l'écran ce que
je vous propose c'est qu'on se fasse une
petite pause de cinq minutes et on se
retrouve et on se retrouve à tout de
suite les mecs
[Musique]
l'élite on est de retour j'espère que
vous avez bien aimé notre petite musique
j'ai envie de vous dire c'est une
musique de qualité à ça va bientôt
devenir un hit un ca pourrait bientôt
sortir le cd ça vaut le savoir et chasse
comme le cd de la musique va bientôt
sortir dans les bacs
je pense pour la rentrée septembre quand
même une musique de qualité
ce serait dommage de vous en priver on
va on va on va bien sûr bien entendu là
vous la mettre à disposition que vous
puissiez la faire tourner chez vous
c'est quand même c'est quand même une
musique de très très très grande qualité
avec avec avec des to tatou toutes les
compositeurs chess points comme de
qualité du grand orchestre
philharmonique d'arizona et avoir la
musique a été composée et dont les
droits n'ont pas n'ont pas n'ont pas été
cédés c'est vrai que ça fait tellement
l'unanimité
on va vous la proposer avec un petit une
petite promotion bien évidemment pour
les membres diamant de tchatche.com il y
aura moins de 50% sur cette musique pour
les membres diamant donc abonnez vous
devenez pas ces diamants sur jazz points
comme très important vous pourrez avoir
le disent quand de 50% et peut-être que
je vous enverrai un cd avec une dédicace
de blanc dédicacé par vlad signé par
blad le cd de la petite musique chaise
comme on passait diamants très important
daniel wrage qui vous le dit à ses
parents qui le dit
un voile attiyah voilà les petits tics
arous ayela hikaru est très heureux yann
nepomniachi respect envers maxime great
choc maxime est ce qu'on te voit
duda attend on ne va pas voir maxime
merde tu joues pas le speech s maxime
adam qu'est ce que c'est que cette merde
maxi chop à le speech est ce au nom mais
c'est la pls la dingli rennes mais on
s'en fout allez hop dégage le là on veut
pas voir le chinois mais non en mai
dégager du 29 novembre au 1er décembre
non mais si y'a pas maxime sérieux les
mecs c'est abusé non non la pls et règne
chez les super heureux sur la vidéo
attend il ya un nom mais ne touche à
rien met sur pause
ah non mais ils ont pas mis le truc du
vrai speech est ce ta pas été invités
non mais sérieusement non mais on est
sérieux maxime non vraiment vraiment
attendez on retrouve sur le match non
vraiment à pas être invité uta où tu es
tu peux pas à cause de non en vrai mais
c'est quoi la raison c'est quoi ce
bordel mais attendez la vente on peut on
peut faire faut faire des lettres c'est
quoi ce bordel pourquoi t'es pas été
invité non mais attends moi je fasse je
suis très énervé là je l'écris à rennes
qui en fait si si t'es sérieux je
m'écris rhein sh un ça va être sauvé
direct en fait elle s'adresse à cause de
ton calendrier mais peu importe je gamme
écrira ray jat petit chèque over
l'avenir cette vente non mais je mets
bien sûr que maintenant nous alors ou
alors je joue tant pis tant pis je joue
et on mettra maximo commentaire hein
c'est pas grave maxime tu m'entraîne aux
échecs je tenterai pas commenter des
bulles attitude elle fera un échange
alors ça va bien se passer je crois
qu'il est le joueur français qui rate
encore une tactique genre français qui
est perdant non mais sérieux ça abusé
sérieuse c'est la mauvaise nouvelle la
j'étais tellement heureux de commenter
les speechs s avec maxime sérieusement
ça m'a mis un petit coup au moral là non
c'est franchement ça a mis un petit coup
de morale
bref envoyer les disques chez orange
mais écoute on va envoyer les disques
chez reine chasse il faut ludwig on va
prouver les no fake et où on ira on
mettra ça sur snapshot ou sur twitter
non mais seront franchement c'est la
mauvaise note ça c'est qu'en gp2
hambourg ça ne sais tu veux que j'aille
sur 2700 de chasse je vais te dire ça le
gp hambourg dire je vais peut-être
passer si tu es bien peut-être je
passerai faire un blog je te ferai pas
chier un t'inquiète mais hambourg en
plus cheval en allemagne depuis un
moment c'est quand gp hambourg s'était
pas en novembre ce truc là tu es la vie
c'est du 10 au 24 décembre
et merci à mg vcac saint bonnet et
twitch prime
j'arrive pas j'arrive plus à le trouver
moi ce truc là à l'essai du 4 au 18
novembre
non mais sérieux il y en a marre lakepa
maxime c'est trop la mauvaise nouvelle
en plus était dispo non mais attends au
maximum viens on écrit à rennes ce site
est chaud on écrit à rennes je n'en mets
jeu là c'est bon on a un gros public
français et où on n'a pas de joueurs
français là qu'est ce que c'est que ça
on fait un scandale il ya rien à faire
non on va se faire chier toute la compet
là on a pas on n'a pas le joueur
français bordel j'ai le droit
et si jamais lu de vie que tu fais un
montage vérifie ce n'a pas été invité
mais si tu as été invités on est on est
obligé de s'énerver un bon on va pouvoir
échapper à colmar edge
bon alors ce match on va voir ça on va
voir sa maxime après je n'ai pas
l'impression ainsi sa cause de ton
calendrier tu peux pas jouer c'est autre
chose toi en excusons torrent excuses
par contrainte qu'on va pas le rater ça
faut le savoir
ah çà çà çà peut pas bien se passer
comme ça c'est pas maxime ça ça va bien
se passer
ça c'est le feu s'ils jouent surtout qu'
il ya des bail avec hikaru maintenant
après ses menaces de mort a peut-être
qu'à et b5 ici qu'elles savent ô qui
avait 5 elle sera peut-être pas
grand-chose qui est peut-être le point 4
à la fin il ya peut-être fou prends moi
j'ai du mal a commenté quand je parle
quand je crois quand je réfléchis quand
je fais les choses droit c'est bien le
tour des huit plus grandes écoles si on
prend des quatre balles quand tu prends
la carlos ne faut pas abuser allez vas-y
lâche toi tu prends des 4 puis on prend
et tu reprends tu reprends un tueur
prend 25
elle n'aura pas le temps de prendre à
des huit ans prise elle va être heureuse
et offrant un f5 et ça va en fait c'est
rien one en reste et c'est n'importe
quoi tour des huit mois j'étais chaud
quand je l'avais saïfi de qualité comme
ça de base mais disent assez bien joué
mais après
bon alors on fait quoi alors mesdames en
russie sur échec parce qu'on aime bien
faire des échecs
voilà ça c'est bien bravo petit tour en
afrique qui fait plaise ouais ça m'a
l'air d'être tranquille cette histoire
bon ce serait cool que vanina gorgan
parce que si elle recolle à 2 points
c'est bien non mais sinon je suis pas
fou qu'ont les démons tôt à la prod
celle ci de là faut qu'on gagne un truc
là y'en a marre non plus de ce pitch
assez cool quand maxime joue il ya des
beaux matchs en plus vraiment c'est des
beaux matchs genre moi j'aurais bien
aimé voir un petit honnêtement j'aurais
bien aimé voir un psy mvl duda perso je
pense que ça pourrait être un très beau
match à suivre deux beau style de jeu
machin ça va pas fermer ni l'un ni
l'autre qui vont fermer le jeu ça peut
donner un super match et el oula ça peut
donner un super match
vraiment ça peut vraiment donner un
super match
zelda et ce serait vraiment ce serait le
feu est levé a une fille ruth déjà on
n'a vu l'autre soir c'était vendredi
soir que deux façons sa lettre de la
pédagogie
tapez atterri dans la boîte mais gbagbo
écrira ray nagin sérieux je comprends
pas honnêtement je comprends pas est ce
qu'ils ont oublié ou quoi mais c'est pas
possible qu'ils n'étaient pas invités
c'est impossible en fait je vais je vais
je vais écrire je écrire ce soir non
mais je vais je vais écrire y'a pas
moyen temps tant pis
c'est génial on va [ __ ] la merde at
chaise comme et tout si forte plastique
on va se faire virer de chez ascom en
l'espace de basse et c'est le dernier
live sur pour tous comme les mecs donc
fait très attention vous ne verrez plus
on va gueuler les mecs quoi fut tout
voir l'incident diplomatique et voilà le
petit matin qui fait plaisir
licenciement direct ouais ça va partir
en licenciement direct les mecs ça
partir ça à partir dans le mal aa et
vanina qui revient à un point où on
attendra deux points en attendant
licenciement hip hop us mais
complètement mais c'est pas possible ne
pas t'avoir sérieux
ce serait génial d'arrêter de commenter
le truc d'aller écrire à rennes chez
tous il est je sais pas si c'est une
speech parce qu'il fout on arrête tout
quoi non mais je pense qu'on va pouvoir
remédier à ça je pense qu'on va pouvoir
remédier à ça franchement donc
ou alors c'est hikaru qui a peur n'at on
vu ses niveau mondial en huit tu vois ça
j'ai envie de te dire le numéro un
mondial n'est pas invitée dans le
tournoi voilà ça c'est vérifiable
il suffit d'aller regarder le site de
1700 thiès
point com et on voit numéro un mondial
au but maxime vachier lagrave c'est pas
hikaru nakamura c'est pas c'est pas
nepomniachi c'est pas c'est pas magnus
carlsen taille car on sur le char comté
qui s'abonner à hikaru et il va nous
vous allez voir dans le tchat
le charpentier no fake il va nous écrire
les gens en train de taper
on m'a offert l'abonnement je vous jure
il va écrire ça vous allez voir le no
fake
le no fake arrive j'ai peut-être dit un
peu tôt par contre mais c'est sûr il va
écrire ça ah il n'a pas écrit il l'a pas
écrit à l on lui a offert l'abonnement
hilla irak avait écrit johnny far cry
alors que c'est pas vrai alors c'est pas
vrai c'est lui qui s'est acheté
l'abonnement sur la chaîne d'hikaru mai
mais il veut pas que ça se sache
il veut pas que ça se sache ces écarts
ou l'autre jour il est un
il a un truc pour par rapport par
rapport à ces menaces de mort en fait y
récupérer de la thune pour pour prendre
des vols pour prendre plusieurs vols
miami miami cannes en fait et du coup il
voit là il faut y faisait un petit
budget et donc est donc le charpentier
l'a pris un abonnement pour pour
participer à ce soft ball en fait donc
donc qui a aidé 5
donc est-ce qu est-ce qui a versé 5 un
jour ou l'autre cas il prend c3 et c5 c5
direct vanina qui est pas mal
vanina qui est pas mal il est pas mal et
pas mal avait pas mal si on prend elle
peut faire tout reprend ses cinq
peut-être et puis 200 m 2 bat je voulais
faire ça mais il ya demain france et 3
et je n'arrive pas à faire fonctionner
le truc j'arrive pas à faire fonctionner
le truc donc peut-être souffert tout
reprend ses cinq direct j'aurais aimé
faire fonctionner france et 3 mais
j'arrive pas à faire
bon ça et le problème c'est que jordan
v6 avait vu un cavalier à 4 qui est
chiant
après on peut faire tout reprend puis on
prend non marche pas je préfère d'amd
site d'amd quatre cavaliers 3 mais il ya
cavaliers des 4 6 1 mais cahier dé 4,5
ok peut-être ça fonctionne peut-être on
peut faire tout reprend ses droits
demain p 6 cavaliers ou 3 mai améliora
d'amd cet échec
ben non ça n'a pas fonctionné du tout en
fait ce truc du ku'damm à 5 j'aime bien
j'aime bien qu'ils aient prend des cinq
dames prend des deux et on reprend des 5
de la tour peut-être à voir mais en tout
cas on met la pression sur lequel ces
trois mais attention quand même aux
dames 17 qui rôdent je sais qu'il ya
roide g8 mais j'aime pas trop me prendre
une dame comme ça sur la 7ème f5 alors
qu'ils aient france et trois
intermédiaires erpion prend il ya des
dames dès cet échec qui rôdent
maintenant mais quelle idée 5 bien jouer
propose les changes des dames découvre
la case 17 puis on prend h7 ok peut-être
on peut prendre des deux tours prend des
deux rois prend à chaud peu pourquoi on
n'est pas obligé de prendre non plus
haut qu'elle prend tout reprend droit
prend h7 qui prend hk peut-être tour c4
ici tour g8 toiture g8 j'aime bien mes
torts gîte à peut-être tour des quatre
au pire y aura un accueil ou trois tours
prend 1,6 ok mais pour ces deux tours
des quatre tours ces deux à tour ces
deux ça a l'air sympa on gagne la
deuxième et on sait de tours l2
ok cavaliers 3 et la tour eiffe six
cavaliers g4 et tour ces deux tours f2
et peut-être tour c'est un du coup
et cavaliers y croire et c'est
exactement ce que j'allais dire on ne
menace le pion g4 et yappa tourcoing f6
parce qu'il ya fourchette et le roi est
pas très bien placé et suroît g3 est
peut-être cavaliers avec 5 à calais 5e
racaille et prend donc roigé trois tours
j'ai bêtement et on chope le pion comme
ça non on est bien là avec les noirs
vanina qui va peut-être remonter les
tongiens wave 5 tour g1 ça donne envie
quand même auquel fait f5 aller vanina a
les petites allées petit je pense que
sur wave 4 la tour prend gk3 prend 1,3
et tour ou pas sûr que ces marchés qui
est peut-être tour f1 ici 3g 2 qui est
de 3 ouais c'est jouer cavalier ou trois
ici f4 après est la joueuse russe ça qui
est bien
f4 les amis et j'ai quelques retours qui
est de 3 qu'est-ce qu'elle fait quelques
3 et 4 c pas logique pourquoi pourquoi
pas qu'est ce qui se passait sur f4
c'était si mauvais a peut-être cavaliers
age ii roi et c'est ok non-retour tour
j'ai trois rois f4 tour j'ai 4 3 points
f5 tous rêvent de tours 2 ici ça va
gagner les mecs il ya tout et tour
attaqué ou pas à ça sent bon la 3.5 sur
tourcoing f6 et un retour projet 4
autour des 7 ouais ok at on pointe 4
tourcoing 4 ça c'est nul mais là le
cavalier à maxime et dans la liste à
avoir la bonne nouvelle
ah ben voilà maxime tu joues c'est très
bien bon ben là c'est dans diplomatique
et éviter ainsi tout envoyer l'un vit
sur cela que fois été mal attendait lé
pas en train de s'auto matella kosteniuk
elle n'est pas en train de s'auto mater
là ok encore échec mais las à venasque
est ici si c'est toi un magma
non y'a roi ici ok faut encaisser le
pion tour échec tant qu est ce le pion
et sajoo allez allez faut jouer vite la
halle et you fallait mettre le roi ici
au nom aïe aïe aïe ça valait
n'inquiétait pas loin là il y avait
quasiment matt leur one le roi qui était
maladroit à 6
bikey par contre je boot ne pas être
dans le teaser on peut faire la
princesse très bien sûr pourquoi
pourquoi t'es pas dans le franchement
vient go on écrit arretche quand même en
fait du coup l'opération de l'opération
rencontre rennes chaque colmar reste en
place et du coup on gueule parce que
t'es pas dans l'est dans les petites
affiches on dit que c'est un scandale
que les spectateurs français était très
énervé on considère ça comme un affront
envers toute la communauté française des
échecs et on demande plus de rester on
en a gros tant pis en gueule oui voilà
on a trouvé ça très déplacé de la part
de check point comme de ne pas rajouter
la petite affiche y'avait dingli rennes
c'est scandaleux même la communauté
francophone way fais tes valises maxime
et bon courage et bonne chance pour pour
le grand duché surcroît à 6
donc il a fait ces quatre là il faut
prendre prisé dame prend des 4 alors
cette position qu est ce que ça vaut
attention grand roque page web scada
prend à 7
donc ça c'est une chose et le pion
dessins qui ont pris 7 6 y jouer au
hockey ou c5 d'un prend des singles
marié d'un proche des 7 aussi mes grands
recolla oh la la
alors la dame prend g7 grand roque
pouces et 5 c'était bien joué mais là
les amis je suis pas confiant il ya tour
g8 damache 3 qui arrive
franchement je suis pas confiant pour
pour vanina dunac émane là les amis il
faut se dire les choses franchement
qu'est tour g8 ça semble juste être un
bon coup bon elle mais l'autre l'une ou
l'autre ça va
damages 6 peut-être pour couvrir un peu
cette case age 3
mais le retour j 6 tours g8 non mais la
dame prend g7 s'étaient c'était un peu
l'opération suicide côté vanina la
difficile pour la joueuse russe ici
c'est un vrai problème auquel il va y
avoir
ok même tout reprend g23 pranger de
dames j'ai quatre échecs roi agenda me
prends un f2 f3 roi j'ai un bon là c'est
abandonna blain il ya tour g8 d'un match
3 vanina acquis qui a fait n'importe
quoi qui fait un cadeau ça faisait
longtemps qu'elle avait plus fait de
cadeaux comme ça sur partie offerte sur
un plateau d'argent à kosteniuk la
menace fou prend aux trois cavaliers f2
menace damas trois là elle peut
abandonner mais vas-y nike va retomber à
moins 3 et c'est dommage parce qu'elle a
manqué l'occasion parties précédentes
et là elle se fait écraser la un petit
coup de fouet des six par exemple pour
menacer tout reproche de maths ça mange
pas de pain
ces morts les mecs vanina qui est vrai
c'est dommage regrette vraiment
l'occasion la partie précédente elle se
fait punir
ouais se fait punir puni moi non il faut
pas te punir ouais ça fait mal ça fait
vraiment très mal là les mecs mais
vanina impassible 1 avait toujours la
même tête posé sa main sur sa joue et
elle joue alors que alexandra plus
expressive à l'écran à l'image c'est du
rhin
c'est dur elle savait pas si son bourdon
elle est impassible vanina elle peut
revenir ya trois points d'écart le match
et pacy est pas il est pas déséquilibrer
ce match gignac a vraiment bien serré
mais elle paye son début de match elle
paye son début de match voilà avec les
noirs à yakhya koala quoi elle à 1 2 3 4
5 contre 4 contre voyelles cavalli qui
vient il ya deux pions plus il ya gros
bordel royet amelia dame price est
surtout fière dame prend f7 surtout donc
croiser cette force et le roi fx adam
preuve cet adam matin d'un incroyable
incroyable incroyable
là c'est la cata c'est la cata vanina
qui voit plus rien et ça fait plus
quatre à y payer cher la ville paye cher
à la petite maison de déconcentration de
vanina ça lui a coûté deux points en
l'espace de trois minutes
c'est wimbledon les mecs c'est wimbledon
les mecs c'est comme assez calmes sur
sur le gazon de wimbledon
elle fait le benoît paire la has et
benoît paire la ctt sortie du jeu tu as
fait tu as fait deux doubles fautes de
fautes directes terre ton et asseoir sur
tâche est a pris 4 as tu as fait deux
double-fautes quatre fautes directes
elle at il appris à léa latine dont
l'ouverture est là tilt en fait d'avoir
raté la finale tout à l'heure quand elle
avait les échecs et elle a fait deux
cadeaux poux sur coup là bas ça fait mal
à la pac à 16h10 parvenant à perdre et
benoît paire ils prendraient leur diby
des nuls ordi nul peut-être fou non ça
peut être jouable si je vais essayer de
tenter le fois je crois qu'ils avaient
bougé f3 mais bon ça me par un peu un
peu un peu impossible ici donc cavagnan
elle menaçait froid il va échanger as un
gros coup au moral
c'est un gros coup au moral
aie aie aie a annoncé dur c'est dur
c'est des cadeaux c'est des cadeaux les
vendanges sans septembre l'a déjà dit
mais sur une chaise comme les vendanges
c'est tous les mois
alors ça là elle fait mal cette partie
là elle fait mal vraiment elle me fait
encore mal dame 37 il fait encore mal
dame price est mate les nex elle avait
pris un math en début de match retour h6
matt 2 2 mais ça fait deux matches quand
même encore le premier match était dur à
voir autant la halle qui a validé si ce
machin s'était pas non plus mais là j'ai
l'impression que le tarif va augmenter
peut-être qui sait si si si pour les
noirs protège le fou ça évite de se
rendre dès des 5 est maintenant foot
français 5 et noir qui s'active pas là
elle fait la différence
alexandra quatre points c'est pas encore
fait mais le problème c'est que
[Musique]
c'est que c'est que c'est les cadeaux
ils sont les cadeaux ils sont co t il
son côté vanina ce soir ça va le changer
ça a fait retour ces deux tours c'est un
on va mettre le pied en b3 à tours en c1
le pion qui va se faire fixer
il va y avoir à 5 qui va arriver mais
tour c'est un là le pion c5 est bien
fixé ça peut le faire pour les blancs
allaient faut absolument recoller l'a
donc 3 l on va faire tour c1
et on va on va quand même on vaque à
mettre la pression sur ce pion c5
il faut absolument qu'elle gagne vanina
il faut absolument qu'elle gagne allez
il faut y aller faire rager deux tons
france et 5 qui va arriver ça va aller
petit à petit les rois g2 et on reprend
ses 5
un airois g2 dans ces 4 or ces deux
à l'étang c4 peut-être la tour en c2 le
roi en g2 et on va les prendre le pion
[Musique]
d'affaires d'amd 1
on remettra la tour en c2 on mettra le
roi eu deux encadrants dans la finale le
pion c'est l'option c5 qui peut être que
protégé peut latéralement par les deux
tours mais là on menace aussi tour 17
tours d'essai est ici tour 17
ton 17 ours et 7e 4 bien joué aussi
tous rêvent troyat roigé deux tours g5
on va pousser les pions
la tortue à toi repartir vers g6 allez
un petit échec et 1 tour 17
allez voilà ça c'est bien joué et tour
des scènes sur torah 5 hier à 4 et les
tourneurs va être complètement
désorganisée allez on fait un petit coup
de 1,4 mais il va falloir rentrer encore
dans les tournois qui sont au bois mais
il va falloir réussir à passer
maintenant
un petit coup de 5 je pense si plus de
hkd de f4 elle veut c activée mais c'est
de l'eau ça un pion prend un enfant
ramener le rang 4 autour des 6 bien joué
ouais menace tout reprend aussi stable
ça va aller là toutou gagne réussit bien
joué et on ramène le roi
qui est ton prince 6 les rois princes 4
au tourcoing f4 même ok to rage 3 et qui
des tours j'ai trois tours h4 causé new
qui se défend c'est vraiment un ces gros
point fort elle défend très longtemps
elle défend vraiment très longtemps et
même quand elle est dans les positions
qui sont qui semble désespérée elle a
réussi à résister quand même très
longtemps et ça fait aussi l'écart à
force ça fait un peu la différence parce
qu'elles continuent elles continuent à
tour aussi c'est marrant au moins elle
va faire rage et où ma mère faisait elle
va envoyer des pions par là elle se
remet des pions ensemble et ça c'est
bien joué elle va réussir à récupérer un
pion l'ami kosteniuk elle est vraiment
très résistante
c'est vraiment sa grosse qualité
roger 4 f 4 on va on va avancer avec les
blancs maintenant tours pas à quatre
tours prend ses 5 et f5 et machin f5
attention et peut-être wife 6,5 et
lessard watch 4g 4 3 et 4 7 3 et 6
étaient plus embêtant parce que là ça y
est ça avance c'est bon la tour j'ai
tour échec qui va arriver et ça rentre
les kosteniuk qui résistent qui
résistent qui résiste un rush 5 j'ai pas
compris
mais maintenant j'ai six tours bouge et
à vii
elle s'attache vite ça et cosim qui
jouent vraiment jusqu'au bout au bout et
c'est même un peu à la limite parfois je
trouve
elle joue jusqu'au dernier piège qu'elle
peut voir après elle fait ce qu'elle
veut hein c'est dans les règles et donc
banana qui revient à 3 points elle peut
regretter la partie qu'elle a donnée
avec le matin en un atout regretter les
cadeaux pour le monde et trois points
d'écart ça se joue sur trois petits
cadeaux de vanina la différence est
ténue mais elle existantes et vanilla
qui peut vraiment s'en vouloir un les
amis à mon avis d'amd sicié
à mon avis les deux joueuses qui sont
vraiment proches fait qu'elle épaississe
mans pourquoi pas personnellement j'aime
bien mettre la dame
fiat est peut-être fou aux quatre ici
vous prend baer décide de partir là bas
la différence est ténue près où tu n' ya
pas le jeu de mots évoluer annoncé tôt
c'est dommage le l'edf set m'a tout à
l'heure ça a coûté cher mais bon allez
peut-être cassé cap qui est des six
on revient avec lecavalier au centre on
va voir où tour huit fois fuite à les
tours 8 peut-être pour avoir du cavalier
e 4 c'est pas assez pas idiot cavaliers
ou 4 peut arriver à tout moment
allez peut-être cassé quatre des six
cavaliers au 4 mai khai ses 4 kg 5
maintenant j'aime bien ce que fait mme
alexandra peut-être tour des huit alors
pour essayé d'insister sur cavaliers ou
quatre en s'en prenant aux pions mais
elle va peut-être faire trois et ça va
revenir au même dame c7 et carrier 17
revenir en f1 et maintenant elle se
prend la marée de pions tous les pions
arrive si on prend fou prend cavaliers
fuite à l'efo couvrir on couvre h7
on met la tour en des 8 et on tape le
pion des quatre allers vanina bats toi
aller retour des 8
allez c'est pas mal quand même elle a
bien réussi à blinder à la trouver le
plan avec aidé cette cavalière fuite
c'est très bien joué de sa part est
maintenant sûr foudroie elle va
peut-être faire qui les dessins qu'elle
va s'en prendre un peu à tout ce qui est
sûr noir le roi des rois g de hockey
dans quelle part de la diagonale
dangereuse elle se met sur blanc
et alors là c'est parti à les focales
faut qu'elle le fasse là
peut-être cavaliers à quatre et c5 pour
pour s'en prendre aux fous et révisé
peut-être la case d3
peut-être
ces 5
je n'ai pas fait ces cinq ce que ça fait
en fait ça fait rien qui sévit qui est
des six peut-être faut replacer ce
cavalier je pense il est mal placé
maintenant peut-être qu'il ya quatre et
c5 était plus fort ouais ouais c'est un
peu compliqué donc j'ai six ou des deux
maintenant il veut venir en c3 des fous
t4 mais maintenant peut-être fou ces
trois quand même
elle va reprendre de la dame et âge si
ce qui peut arriver mais peut-être qu'il
prend des 5 c'est pas clair mais juge
aime pas du tout ce cavalier ici
m'énerve il m'agace alors elle prend des
5 et tours 3 waouh
alors ça alors ça fallait le voir
qu'est ce que c'est bien joué de la part
de vanina maintenant que le fou était
plus en d2 contre les plus la case 3
elle plante cavaliers prend des 5
elle règle le problème du cavalier or il
peut y avoir foule prend avec cet échec
intermédiaire mais c'est pas grave au
moins ont fait d'artprice est donc se
débarrasser du problème du cavalier qui
était qui n'était pas le plus fort
vanina là qui fait une grosse partie
allez allez vanyda à les marques marques
allez il faut mac il faut gagner là il
faut il faut qu'elle devienne la
valentine à ces hyper hyper hyper
important faut qu'elles reviennent à
deux points il reste combien de temps il
reste 26 minutes dans le 3 + 1 allez
allez vanina recolle que c'est new kiss
eu la forêt près moved 1.97 faut lui
apprendre l'art des prêts move à vanina
là il faut presser la pendule aussi dame
g4 elle laisse du coup dès 5 ans prise
c'est fait fana vanina vanina vanina
ferait fuit dont roy prend et manon
peut-être des petits coups de tour des
trois tours d2 f5 ou là peut-être dame
ses six précédents du tour pranger cinq
échecs le cas échéant
en plus j'aime bien même satisfait au
sein et bien jouer la joueuse russe
peut-être tour d2 maintenant avec l'idée
surtout rêve de tout reprend et tours
j'ai 3 à 3,2 et on g3 ces cadeaux ou pas
encore il pourrait s qui peut y avoir du
contenant elle l'a pas fait mais puis on
prend f5 très fort aussi puisque ça
gagne le cavalier de en force et vanina
qui revient à l'est vanina vanina qui
est de retour dans le match et n'est
plus qu'à deux points de son adversaire
elle est revenue là elle et elle recolle
complètement la joueuse la joueuse russe
elle recolle à 2 joueurs à deux points
de l'autre joueuse russe donc deux
joueuses russes qui recolle
et elle peut revenir il faut juste
serrer le jeu maintenant et pas avoir
les petites sautes d'attention qu'elle a
pu qu'elle a pu avoir qui ont coûté des
points je vous le rappelle un match raté
en début de match à un problème de
connexion
bon ça revient sur des petites erreurs
elle a perdu on va dire deux trois
points et c'est les 2 3 points qui
manquent mais sinon dans le contenu
c'est pas mal à l'aise on va peut-être
ok la côte et blanc des troquets dame b
8 contrôler la casse des six c'est
important comment est-ce que vanina va
continuer et elles contrôlent l attaque
que c'est un peu le pion b2c tendu pour
vanina n'ya pas droit à l'erreur
elle s'est mis dans le dur avec son
début de match de toute façon c'est
vraiment dans la première demi heure
quel c est allé allait pas bien rentré
dans son match aller peut-être cave a
lieu cinq ici carrillo 500 pêche petit
rock quand même parce que s'attaque le
pion 17
elle fait tourner un sens pêche petit
rock aussi en attaquant le pion 17
scipion des bougel +6 derrière écossais
new qui doit encore régler un problème
était tuera du fou et si ça à trois
moments donnés pour essayer de placer un
carrier des singles je ne sais pas
ah les dames bessette est ce que
cavaliers au sein qui six candidats
peut-être peut-être avec des idées
peut-être de fou prend avec cissé d'un
match 5 échecs ça peut être candidat les
mecs et ses jouets allez vanina qui
viendront nouvelles menaces vous
progressé de 4 ans 17
elle est bien vanina a les valides à
vanina vanina vanina vanina le stade est
en folie
attention les mecs les 50000 spectateurs
qui sont autour qui gueulent vanina
vanina ils sont là ils sont tous là et
kosteniuk est dans le dur
moi ce qui me fait juste un peu peur
c'est la connexion de vanina qui est pas
très solide et qui pourrait coûter en
bullet mais sinon elle est vraiment bien
dans son match maintenant sur des six on
peut peut-être même rêver à de peut-être
fou prend un f6 dame j'ai six échecs g6
qui étrangers six d'un projet si ce 3e
set mais y'a rien d'autre peut-être un
petit coup allez faut maintenir la
pression la foux prend f6 et cava lieu
qu'à trail surfe ou prend il ya damage
cinq échecs et 1.5
alors il a traité un petit rock
maintenant peut-être petit rock
comment faire cavalier des six peut-être
à ce moment là on battrait son petit
rock semble seul coup les mecs je vois
pas d'autre but que petit rock ici très
honnêtement
parce que sinon qui a été si c'est
chacun arrive au prochain les petits
roms qu'est-ce qu'il va y avoir est ce
que ces qualifs si c'est ce que ces
caïds et 6 aces claqués ses 5 eca et 17
y accueille ses 5 et 17 aussi il y avait
encore une autre menace
et ce après deux pions ça fait mal là
pour kosteniuk y est mal paraître peut
recoller à un point vanina elle n'est
pas loin là et kosteniuk irréfléchie
kosteniuk qui comprend qu'elle est
tombée sur plus forte qu'elle
vanina qui fait toujours la même tête
depuis tout à l'heure ça fait ça fait
une heure et demie qu'elle fait la même
tête deux heures même s'il y avait un
concours de celui qui peut faire le même
visage le plus longtemps possible
vanyda ne serait pas loin du titre de
championne du monde c'est vrai qu'elle a
un talent à ses incomparables
quoi qu'il se passe toujours le même
visage c'est beau genre de statues
vivantes petit rang cac et ses 5 et 17
qui va partir abîme tempo kosteniuk
issue il est issu en plus elle va
pouvoir encore rebondir pour choper du
matos peut-être même ce cavalier qui
prend 17 pour choper e6 là qui peut qui
peut raser du lourd là bas elle peut
raser 17 et rasé et rasé et rasé au
cices elle va avoir pris trois pions en
l'espace de trois coups est un pro sys
manants qui semble jouable
c'est vrai que ça fait plein de raser
tous les pions de son adversaire tous
les pions sans trop c d e qui vont
tomber
allez vanina vanina qui est bien vanina
qui est donc ou vanilla qui a des plans
plus d'âme g4 elles menacent pas encore
cavaliers fcm des menaces de menacer des
trucs là à yale cavalli emprise ou ou
vanina qui est partout tourer maintenant
probablement on va venir échanger un peu
des pièces et peut-être tour doit être
tourer tour un spar est sympa pour un
petit peu échangé
c'est pas le seul point
tout va jouer kosteniuk et mal autant
plus que 10 secondes sur cavaliers ou
cinq ans puis sa cavale et prend 2,5
pour preuve un tour prochain menace
qu'est praxis échec est un français vite
maintenant il y en a qui menace du lourd
que ses new skies pour le moment s'en
sort mais la vallée l'un qui réfléchit
et qui va trouver ajouta même si ça
brasse dames 8 pour faire maths et dames
8 tout en souplesse
vanina très souple magna qui a fait du
yoga ce matin et vanina qu'ils
l'emportent allez tu reviens on sait
bien jouer c'est bien joué de la part de
vanina qui revient à un point ce match
est complètement fou elle remonte quand
on pensait qu'elle était au fond elle
avait donné deux parties elle était
retombé à moins 4 on avait enterré
vanina on avait dit ça et là vanina
n'est plus dans le coup
vanina a craqué et kosteniuk qui va
l'emporter et finalement non vanina qui
ressort de chez les morts qui revient
des morts et qui a un point maintenant
qui peut égaliser et ça fait bien
longtemps
la dernière fois qu'il avait égalité
c'était à la deuxième partie de ce match
un partout et depuis ça que c'est nous
qui est monté à 4 1 et l'écart n'a
jamais été plus faible que deux points
c'est la première fois de vanina revient
à un point mais là attention le pion est
venu en f4 et le fou de vanina est en
danger est en danger parce qu'on ménage
et 4 f 5
allez allez allez vanille d'un revient
batwa remonte il reste combien de temps
il reste seize minutes kosteniuk y
envoie alors que ces outils bouffe des
gâteaux et vanina qui ne mangent pas
vanyda qui fait la même tête
impressionnant
c'est impressionnant quand même un
vanina qui est impressionnante de
concentration jouer ce très sympathique
et attention de ne pas faire bouger si
peut-être fou j'ai six sacs et prendre
cette prise aux 7 et f5 qui traînent
jazz unités du suspense oui aux caprices
et trois prix c'est toi f6 et elle se
donne de l'air pour son fou et que c'est
mieux qu'ils réfléchissent à elle mange
parce qu'elle sent qu'elle est dans le
dur
alexandra qui est dans le dur belle
joueuse après aussi c'est vraiment des
joueurs de qualité des joueuses de
qualité tour 8 fouet fuite peut-être
pour bien l'un des cavaliers a fuité
elle refait comme tout à l'heure à elle
défend avec lecavalier et abidal qui
qu'il a joué exactement cette position
contre vanina et avait gagné j'imagine
et au cra sayah mathieu aussi qui est
dans le chat a été vous avez vous êtes
tous venus là du coup mathieu qui est
venu aussi encourager vanina pas aller
bien dedans
elle est bien dans la joueuse russe
elle remonte elle fait vraiment une
grosse série là elle fait vraiment une
grosse série elle est à moins 4 elle
remonte à l'est peut-être tour des huit
on va menacer un peu le pion des 4 de
toute façon at on le choix tour des huit
jouer pour eux un peut-être pour menacer
le fou va arriver il va falloir prendre
une décision côté vanina food et 6 elles
menacent le pion f4 et peut-être
provoque un petit peu cavalier prend des
six elle pourra peut-être reprendre de
la tour doubler les tours sur des
peut-être même du tour b 6 ou du tour
quelque chose qui arrive à un moment
donné elle est tout reprend la dame
prend la prépare du tour c'est 8 elle va
jouer sur les colonnes dame c5 attention
la dame recul est peut-être un petit
coup de fouet des cinq maintenant qui va
arriver un peu plus tard pour venir s'en
prendre aux rois série que les blancs
ont fait une grosse expansion allait
droit mais du coup le problème c'est que
l'europe peut rester faible allez
maintenant il ya pioncer 3 visé aussi il
ya pas mal de choses à faire là pour
pour les noirs
est ce qu'elle va faire b 600 premiers
histoire de couvrir un peu tous ses
pions ou tour ses huit mois je partirai
mais un produit tour sémites perso tant
pis pour le pion à sa terrasse et trois
en cas ou au cas où fou prend à deux
mais d'un franc à 2 contre échec
olala vanina au lagaffe oh là là là on
se croirait sur tf1 vincent lagaf
incroyable incroyable cette gaffe à
vanina des petites scories comme ça fou
prend 1,2 après un 2e échec
catastrophique elle était bien revenu
revenu à une craque sur des petites
erreurs là vanyda c'est dommage on a
vraiment l'impression d'avoir un peu
comme un comme un match de tennis avec
avec une joueuse bat li na qui tape plus
fort dans la balle qui traverse bien ses
coûts mais qui joue un peu plus à plat
et du coup elle prend plus de risques et
à certains moments ça craque alors que
chess queen
elle joue un peu plus lifté et le chien
qui aboie très énervé mais là c'est
incroyable cette erreur de vanina qui
paie un peu ces petites sautes de
concentration et le chien qui est très
énervé bien évidemment par sept par
cette gaffe de vanilla
le chien en sueur c'est vrai que c'est
assez décevant de faire des gaffes comme
celle là et le chien qui qui montre son
mécontentement en pleine rue alors
tourbe et 8
est ce qu'on peut mettre le pion aux
quatre ici et à peut-être cavaliers c5
et sa paire le pion aux quatre aulas et
festivals de la gaffe pour vanina vanina
qui craquent une nouvelle fois dans ce
match c'est incroyable c'est du benoît
paire a séduit benoît paire tout craché
incroyable quand même sept joueuses
capables de faire des parties
remarquable et puis après par la suite
sur des petites erreurs simple un fou
prend 1,2 après deux échecs eu quatre
cavaliers ces cinq sur des petites
fautes
elle est capable de redonner le pouvoir
à son adversaire à défaut
en profiter avec camaïeu 5 je pense
qu'il fallait plutôt prendre du fou et
ça revient à l'est on va prendre ces six
ici et finalement ça va bien se passer
ne t'inquiète pas ça va bien se passer
allez ça peut le faire il faut revenir
s'il faut penser si ce qui est
envisageable d'ailleurs qui a vu de
l'échec non pourquoi pas d'un prend elle
veut pas laisser qui ont se remettre et
c'est peut-être pas si grave que ça
t'apprend à 6 voilà c'est ça qu'on veut
dans le processus maintenant et le pion
à qui file à l'est vanina sait ça pas
été bien l'erreur de vanina qui n'a pas
qui n'a pas été fructifié par par par
kosteniuk qui finalement la donne elle
fameuse option a passé avec le fourrage
et de passer du fisher time and of les
mecs c'est du cousu main
là il ya l'autoroute du pion time and
off en sueur face à face à ce pion à et
là ça va pousser
voilà ça va pousser du lourd à les
envoyer à 5 à 6 peut-être même foudroie
d'abord on balance le pion b2 on s'en
fout et on pousse comme des malades
allez il faut y aller non mais t'es pas
d'accord mathieu qui avec elle fait
comme benoît paire on prend vraiment
benoît paire s'est tu joues bien tu
joues bien tu joues bien et puis après
pendant 2-3 je sais pas ce que c'est
parce que tu fous tu foutais balle dans
le filet la graverie avait complètement
rey a et c'est parti
un message qu'elle manque régulièrement
de régularité failli verser toutes ses
phrases sombré en fait elle est
régulière dans son manque de régularité
caïds et 5 très bien joué kosteniuk qui
se laisse pas faire qui est des cinq qui
est bien joué elle vient reprend le
contrôle de à 8 à les renvoyer le pion
jusqu'à 7 allée couloir numéro un
usain bolt c'est ça mathieu couloir
numéro un il est là il est parti couloir
numéro 3 lemaitre qui va peut-être
partir mais bon il fait quand même moins
peur allez ça va y aller il faut la
mener jusqu'en à 7 du scène et après on
essaiera d'aller taquiner un peu avec du
tour b vite on verra ce qu'on fait il
est bien parti ce pion et c'est
important pour vanina c'est important
parti importantissime dame b 5 alors est
ce que cette finale deux tours qu'est ce
qu'elle vaut de toute façon je pense
qu'on n'a pas de plus value à garder la
dame ici
j'imagine qu'il va falloir l'échangé et
envoyé pion à 6 à 7 ou pas moi j'ai la
chance de ne pas jouer du coup c'est pas
mon problème
mais bon peut-être ailleurs ces cinq
peut-être faut commencer par tours b 1re
es bien joué trop bien parce que surtout
reprend tour prend tour à 8 à 6 tours
prend tourbe et huit fois fuite il ya
poussé 5 à la fin et du coup le pion qui
va aller jusqu'en à cette allée vanina
aller t'es pas loin elle n'est pas loin
vanilla elle n'est pas loin allez prise
prise et à 6 voilà c'est ça c'est
exactement la varende convient de la
variante pardon qu'on vient de voir
et sur ces 5 à 7 quand même et la tour
qui va arriver en bessette faut insister
sur ce pion à vanina qui va pouvoir
installer la tour en 17 et après ramener
son roi ça va rentrer ça et kosteniuk
yves avoir raté une occasion quand même
parce que vanina avait gaffé cas et
c'est ça qu'il fallait sûrement plutôt
jouer vous prend 1,4 que cavaliers pros
eux quatre c'est un tournant du match
c'est un nouveau tournant du match les
mecs c'est en train de tourner de
nouveau un petit peu en faveur de la
joueuse
bruce est alors l'assura satis pasqua
attendez on a perdu la partie
génisses clic nom est revenu à cette c5
est tombé cette voie là c'est jouer mais
il y avait foule prend ses cinq dents il
y avait foule prend ses 5 fu prend ses
cinq tours b 8 échecs
même moi je n'ai vu aucun cas le voit au
coup d'après est tombé huit échecs c'est
bon et on prend à 8
et là il suffit juste un peu de jouer
droit et ça va aller tranquillement
jusqu'à la trêve 3 g 4 dès que le roi
passe sur une colonne aller touré fuite
fo prend 1,7 point à 9,7 et on prendra
ça a été c'est fini la nina qui revient
à l'ema nina à les patois fonds donnes
tout ce que tu as on pensait qu'ils
allaient les retombées à -3 lagaf été
faite elle revient à moins un
elle s'accroche et c'est là qu'il faut
recoller à l'est c'est là qu'il faut
recoller c'est hyperimportant faux
débreaké l'afo débreaké allez ça va bien
se passer
c'est chaud les mecs c'est chaud tarifs
5 et bien placé donc il va peut-être
venir en c5 on va mettre la pression sur
le centre à quoi ça vous fait penser
qu'elle est la structure de pions qu'on
est en train de voir là les mecs si les
noirs ou c5 aller quelle est la
structure est ce que dans le chaton peut
nous le dire c'est pour aider vanina les
mecs
allez on est de vanina en lui disant en
dix ans la structure allez on fait on
fait tout ce qu'on peut on va voir
est ce que le chat aime française bien
jouer et rejouer si on réussissait à
jouer c'est ça qu'on n'a pas réussi mais
il faut aider vanina il faut lui dire
quelle structure de pions joue c'est
très très important
peut-être car la libre en d4 ici je sais
pas si ça fonctionne
faux projet si ce qui est pris avec
trois échecs est-ce que qui est prend
des quatre fonctionné je met un petit
coup d'ordi j'aurais peut-être quelque
chose eh oui ça fonctionnait aïe aïe aïe
elle a raté
elle a raté allez c'est pas grave c'est
pas grave peut-être on peut mettre la
tour ans et 8 préparer du c5 a peut-être
fois h5 aussi pour pour clouer un peu
tout ça pour ces huit j'aime bien
peut-être c5 qui va se préparer
allez on est bien et salua le ring dans
le chat qui est là pour la première fois
à l'essai 5 peut-être on ouvre tout
allez on attaque sur tous les azimuts et
on fout le bordel on ne la fera
peut-être que l'on prend et puis on
reprend et jouer sur des multiples
courage dont elle prend ici en premier
effet ces cinq maintenant bon c'est
quand même bien elle veut peut-être
prendre ici prend 10 6 kgs c5 et des 5
le match qui est vraiment vraiment tendu
on a bien compris des forces en présence
un le lift de kosteniuk un livre assez
puissant qui lui permet de mettre
beaucoup de balles dans le court
côté côté vanina des balles plutôt à
plat un peu moins d'effet un peu moins
de sécurité sur la hauteur du filet sur
les longueurs de balle mais des coups un
peu plus puissant c'est une opposition
de styles avec les pour les deux gamins
jouent un jeu un jeu tiré tourné vers
l'offensive
cavalier c5 il va sûrement le prendre
peut-être pas le laisser arriver en haut
4 quoi que elle peut peut-être le
laisser on va voir
dams et 2 il reste six minutes il reste
deux parties ont trois plus un
normalement quoique pas sur ça dépend
combien de temps et de coups durs celle
là et puis on prend ça va les prend et
maintenant cet appui qui se dirige vers
des six les cavaliers qui ont des casses
dans cette partie et c'est vrai qu'il
décide ça paraît un peu pénible à
première vue il n'y a pas de découverte
quoique qui est des 6 kg et b3 à b2
prend b3 pardon je craque pour ces 6 je
craque complètement mais là on menace
cavaliers prend 1,4 ont masqué prend 1,4
turfoo prend ses cinq peut-être fou
prend ses 5es et prend c'est de nouveau
très tactique un peu d'âme b6 prises et
ours et 8 on s'active de folie le
puy-en-velay 3 sera pas très puissant
c'est ça c'est vanina nadal contre
alexandra federer c'est vraiment le
bordel mais une nouvelle fois vanina qui
a mis le pied sur l'accélérateur c'est
kosteniuk y est mal autant j'ai peur que
c'est lui que soit plus entraînés en
bullet ça m'inquiète un petit peu mais
en tout cas c'est plutôt vanina qui
réussit à jouer vite et c'est kosteniuk
irréfléchie dame à 2 alors ça passe a
pas la tête du bon coup peut-être un
coup comme cavaliers detroit ici déjà
peut être une option car et f4 peut être
une option mais qui est des trois jeunes
ce qu'on a ce cas c'est un et vous
feront des six j'aime bien qu'ils aient
des trois première vue elle fait dame 17
j'aimais bien et j'ai bien qu'elle ait
des trois mais bon ça pas été joués
prêcher pas quel point cet effort battu
laissait pas vraiment baisse est ce que
tu as et qu'elle sert allez on
s'accroche cavaliers à 6 elle veut jouer
peut-être pour vous ces 3 ou cavani c3
permettre le cavalier en b 4 elle menace
aussi fou des six le cas et qui revient
fous ces cinq elle va elle veut échanger
une pièce à les tours c8 peut-être le
fou qui va revenir en b 4 pour attaquer
la tour d2 à mon avis serait pas idiot
s'est joué alors sur tours ici on a
peut-être cavalière carte maintenant le
fou est cloué il pourra pas bouger il ya
la tour derrière il faudra réussir à
faire fructifier des cavaliers 4 et tour
ces deux qui rentre ouais c'est en train
de peut-être pour ses deux mains en
rajoute ou tempo
c'est en train de rentrer et peut-être
cavaliers eu deux tours c'est un
maintenant et tour c'est 1 et tours c1
dames des trois tours prend des 1 et
tours c'est un le retour et tout reprend
d un tour c'est un bon ça sera pas
encore fini parce qu'il faudra encore la
gagner mais ça prend forme d'amd 500
prend à la tour de cavaliers c5
maintenant qui va arriver pour s'en
prendre option b 3 c'est vrai que
scipion b3 tombe ça ferait mal elle fait
pousser 5 allait peut-être cahier p 4
échecs va peut-être faire tisser 6
maintenant quel étudiant un peu revenir
ou pas à lagardelle card le fou en jeu
c'est peut-être bien joué ça vaut
vraiment la gagner c'est là c'est
important de recoller enfin au score
c'est tellement longtemps qu'on n'a plus
été à égalité 2
ça envie de se retirer des trois
cavaliers affectés à cette histoire là
pour aller taper une plongée deux et ça
permettrait surtout tape espions de
faire rentrer la dame est fou b4
maintenant là ça ça va ça va converger
qu'avait lieu en premier fou des quatre
cavaliers detroit et cavaliers france
est un
et c'est fini yes vanina qui revient à
égalité à ce match qui tient toutes ses
promesses ce match qui tient toutes ses
promesses
on est à 10 partout il reste une minute
une partie de 3 + 1 puisqu'il reste
qu'une minute et quelques de trois
puissants et après on se lancera dans
les bulles est les deux joueuses qui
n'arrivent pour le moment pas à se
départager
le match est serré comme jamais
c'est incroyable aucune des deux
joueuses ne réussit à prendre le dessus
elles sont toutes les deux avec leurs
points forts et leurs points faibles et
kosteniuk ou wael el elle cligne un
petit peu des yeux elle est dans le dur
elle sent que 6,6 vanina réussi à avoir
la régularité
elle gagnera le match l'écossé new qui
doit pas lâcher
alexandra nadal qui doit qui doit
continuer à jouer le même jeu espéré que
son adversaire traque bobby fischer qui
nous lâchent plus d'infos dans le chat
il nous dit kosteniuk va gagner en
bullet écoute bien malin pourra dire qui
va gagner en bullet parce que vanina
elle me paraît quand même assez
impressionnante elle joue vite
elle m'a l'air d'être en forme ça va
être très tendu comme match en tout cas
c'est vraiment le match de l'année en
speech est franchement on a vu des
bosses pitch juniors il ya eu du
sévillan contre contre
[Musique]
mial sarine il ya eu d'autres matches
mais là c'est vraiment serré auquel
quelqu'un qui a balancé de l'eau sur le
balcon alors des quatre qui a été sept
joué à troyes protège le pion d'alger 5
peut-être f4 il s'est passé quoi f4 la
dame qui va être chassé la matière
partir en h6 ou angers troyes alors
cette dame est ce qu'on peut l'enfermer
est ce qu'on peut en faire mais cette
dame foulée trois menaces cavaliers
prend aussi ce qui comprend aussi sous
près de six mille cavaliers 17 qui
traînerait ok s'est défendu peut-être un
coup comme qu'est ce qu'on peut jouer
ici avec les blancs c'est une bonne
question
andres et de suivre ce qui se passe
apparemment c'était peut-être un lancer
de javel vous relancez d'eau on ne sait
pas sa part de tous les côtés les amis
c'est un peu la folie alors cavalia
fuite qui blindent le pion dame f2 ça va
échanger que va-t-il se passer peut-être
un pion qui peut arriver à f/5 ont eu
quatre g4 g5 paquet à 4 le pion v6 qui
est menacée il y avait les cavaliers ou
cas 3g un ex-champion poussera peut-être
qu'ils et b6 pour gagner la colonne
c'est ben c'est très compliqué comme
position québécismes va être jouée
goulinat qui à 25 secondes de retard
pour le moment la pendule mais rien
n'est fait alors ça échange prise fou
des six mais savait que les blancs la sq
a valu en baisse il est finalement très
mal placé il peut plus ressortir ya plus
de casse pour le cavalier f5 devront
s'en prend aux options us 6 / 5 ça
donnera comme ça une case au cavalier
peut-être avec la caf des 5
il ya peut-être le pion à vii en ligne
de mire et on va vouloir faire du cavaly
c6 hawaï en a vraiment partout les mecs
la position qui est vraiment ultra
complexe il ya le pion eu 600 prises on
a vraiment partout et peut-être des
coups comme fou g3 aussi acquis les
fouette de fou prend 3 qui peuvent
traîner de l'autre côté
honnêtement ça traite de partout et
c'est compliqué
c'est vraiment compliqué les mecs bien
malin celui qui pourra deviner l'issue
du match et l'issue de la partie mais
fou g3 paraître un point intéressant ici
mais après cinq pions prends ça menacera
de cette fourchette paraissait très
complexe tours 8
défend le pion prise prisé savais que ça
empêche un peu les cavaliers c6 mais il
ya peut-être cavaliers de 17 ici qui
peut traîner maintenant à un moment
donné mais un cavalier ici qui protège
alors le fou qui repart et food et 4
alors elle protège ici elle protège ici
kg 3 peut-être pour ces deux ici pour
pour parer les chèques mais a peut-être
fou aux 4 qui est pénible sur why they à
cavaillon e4 donc faux et 4 va jouer
dans cavagne f5
elle repart pour attaquer le fou fou
c'est 5 fu écarter un tour d2 semble
intéressant dans ce temps là et il ya
peut-être du fou prend et fluide fou
prend aussi ce qui peut traîner
il ya peut-être aussi du cavalier de 17
avec l'idée de rentrer avec la tour sur
17 maintenant le cavalier qui parle à
cavalli g5 ou cavalli g5 les amis via le
plus réussi sans l'air il ya le fou en
l'air y'a pas fou des cinq kosteniuk qui
a de nouveau craqué incroyable
incroyable que c'est nous qui craque
complètement face à face à sa
compatriote valentina qui en train de
sortir un match d'un autre monde
là il faut prendre si ce qui va rentrer
et ça va être fini et vanina qui va
tourner à plus simple c'est
extraordinaire les mecs kg 3 mais elle a
peut-être juste un coup comme vous
prendrai bêtement et tour des huit ici
et c'est matt du couloir et ça tourne
plus un valide à qui n'avait plus mené
depuis la première la première partie et
on va mettre une petite pause
avec je vais essayer à je vais vous
laisser trois minutes moi je vais
essayer de fermer les volets sûr de
pouvoir gueuler chez moi pendant le
pendant leurs pendants de bullet qui va
être extraordinaire goût nina qui mène
d'un point
il reste trente minutes ça va jouer
maintenant les mecs on se retrouve tout
de suite l'élite
dans cinq minutes le dénouement du match
[Musique]
bon les mecs ça va repartir pour le
bullet avec vanina en grande forme qui
mène de plus un on va voir ce que ça
donne dans ce match aller on est là
alors là on va envoyer j'ai laissé le
volet ouvert finalement tant pis c'est
la vie mais parti comme ça de cette
façon là il n'est pas trop tard famille
les que 9 heures et encore plein de
plein de bruit dans la rue on peut on
peut se faire plaisir
je vais remettre du coup les affiches
des tournois nous qui nous lie n'hésitez
pas à mettre des petits liens à mettre
des petits des petites choses pour que
les gens puissent suivre le match
là ça va vraiment être extraordinaire
allez on va se faire plein on voit que
bientôt il y aura le fisher en dôme
premier tournoi dimanche prochain de
fisher en dôme
normalement je suis inscrit pour les
jouer après je sais pas peut-être je
sais pas si je les jours et tous parce
qu'il ya beaucoup de stream en ce moment
mais possible que ça que sa voix
toujours le seul saturdays tous les
samedis vous pouvez jouer sur czech
comme contre des soldes allez ça va
envoyer voile affidés title fusée avec
maxime
alexandra kosteniuk alexander great
chioukhs et hikaru nakamura qui fait un
petit sourire au regard de côté on voit
un qui gratte un petit peu ses mains un
petit peu comme une mouche qui aurait
pour plan de m des menaces de mort a
bien donc on voit bien
hikaru voilà on voit bien encore les
photos il car ou qui me regarde on le
voyait bien sur la photo d'avant ilove
chahine a dit m richard notre chaise
tout distrowatch à celles de fisher en
deux chaises tous types chasse going
voilà bobby fischer qui est la reine qui
refait sa pub est ce qu'il aura mis les
cartes de mvf cette fois ci on ne sait
pas donc
habia caruana alexander great chouk
hikaru nakamura
peter zeidler magnus carlsen et daniel
reds vous pouvez trouver l'intrus yafi
route ja aussi à ça c'est moi ça ça
c'est moi qui me qualifie d' hannah
arendt qui t'explique que tu peux faire
les qualifs
alors il raconte un petit peu et fait sa
petite pub très heureux il te fait un
petit signe de la main
alors c'est bien ce que je disais ça
commence le dimanche 30 juin pour les
qualifs et on aura douze ans tout en
dise plus 2 fabiano caruana hikaru
nakamura ils sont tous là magnus carlsen
et dany reich qui revient pour nous
refaire sa pub donc des pourquoi zwiller
on sait pas c'est pas tabou ce pas tabou
alors lasserre plaisir sur ce budget qui
va démarrer dans très peu de temps à
l'esa est parti là sont tous là avec
l'échiquier le puits en d4 d5 allez ça
va repartir
allez on est reparti goulinat qui mène
d'un point à l'est vanina contre
alexandra qui vous décider qui va gagner
d'après vous c'est parti cavaliers f3
donc la joueuse la joueuse russe qui
engage avec qui j'ai trois fous j'ai de
le flanquer tôt le fou qui est bien
placé le fait qu'ils s'en rendent et 7
des 4 6 h 3 fou prend elle tron l'a déjà
vu dans ce match
le cavalier qui va venir en aide si ce
le fouet cette petit rock les blancs qui
vont peut-être joué avec ses quatre
cavaliers en c3 le pion aux quatre ça va
envoyer deux partout sur quelle idée de
voile elle sécurise le pion c4 fawcett
pion aux quatre plus tôt plus on prend
cavaliers prendre cavaliers qui va
reprendre le fou qui va prendre dans
petit rock d'abord les blancs qui vont
essayer de jouer sur la sur la force au
säntis vont peut-être faire ces trois
fouet khaddam des deux tours d un tour
heures ils vont venir se placer côté
noir la difficulté servant de savoir ici
comment on veut
tim et parce que si on met le pion à ses
cinq le problème c'est que le fouet f3
va taper sur le pion bessette et ça
c'est un vrai problème donc on doit
garder un petit peu cette position tendu
sans toucher à rien et c'est très
difficile à faire en bullet parce qu'en
bull est ce qu'on veut faire évidemment
c'est prendre l'initiative le fou qui
vient f4 food et six en échange les
pièces le fou dont il recula les tours
des huit tours ces huit tours 8 le 5
alors là il faut plutôt jouer pour eux
cinq ici à mon avis parce que si on
bouchet 5 c'est le fou g2 qui va vivre
et se fou j'ai deux on ne veut surtout
pas le faire vivre donc la tour qui
vient 8 maintenant le pion qui va partir
au 5 allée il faut jouer aux cinq vanina
il faut envoyer faut prendre
l'initiative tu peux pas attendre en
budget c'est pas possible alors vanina
qui prend son temps
est ce qu'elle va faire qui étaient 500
à 5 pour le moins il fixe peut-être que
le car arrive à venir en d5 pour
attaquer le fou peut-être le pion eux
c'est un conte s'est pas quitté saint
cloud et de comment je veux pour vanina
il faut vraiment faire quelque chose
c'est dur l epa entreprenante elle
attend et à ce petit jeu là normalement
c'est la joueuse
l'autre joueuse russe sa compatriote
alexandra kosteniuk qui devrait tirer
profit de cela parce que tout simplement
parce que en bullet ne rien faire c'est
ce que je vous explique depuis tout à
l'heure c'est difficile donc tour 8 il
faut envoyer aux 5
c'est peut-être pas le meilleur coût
c'est peut-être pas un coup toujours en
partie longue mais c'est obligatoire à
un moment donné de envoyé le 5 de
renvoyer le jeu ou peut-être b6 et 5 mai
il faut faire quelque chose il faut
entreprendre
sinon la pendule c'est en ce qu'est en
train de se passer cool cool cool et tu
finis par perdre donc elle prend à eux
cinq prises cinq reprises aux 5
il va leur tour prend fou prend toujours
un petit avantage blanc mais c'est pas
grand chose
peut-être que les noirs ont encore
échangé les tours avec tour des limites
on se rentre dans une finale avec la
paire de fou contre fou cavaliers mais
on sait que les cavaliers ça fait des
fourchettes d'un bécistes entre un joli
piège avec franges et 3 mais servira à
cause d'arrêt à cause de fouilles 3
plutôt qu'à valider cette peut-être pour
mettre le fou un f6 ta meuf ça très bien
joué les blancs qui menace le cavalier
maintenant il va falloir s'en sortir
peut-être cavaliers c5 menace l'option b
3 il va falloir aller le chercher mais
celle prend ce pion v3 pas forcément
derrière elle aura plus grand chose
parce que il y aura plus grand chose en
défense ira du fou et 4 et ça peut faire
mal
attention il faut jouer vite plus que 9
secondes g6 intermédiaire dams et de
leur tour cavaliers 6 allez il faut il
faut serrer le jeu dans abc
aures auto cloud oulala l'auto clouage
mais elle menace faut prendre la menace
où pranger 3 elle tente un petit chipeau
fou prend à nantes où pranger 3 qui
marchait plus alex ou g7 fawcett est
levée
elle veut dam des quatre peut-être et
cavaliers prend des 3a les dames des 4 l
envoi la tour qui va peut-être partir en
des 8 mai peut-être échanges prises les
pions des trois qui reste en prise c'est
très tendu les amis autour des 8 qui va
peut-être jouer food et de food est de
fous des docks et prend des trois qui
marchait pas d'âme à troyes le tour qui
est sous pression la dame qui peut aller
en un tour des huit autour des 8
peut-être oui elle que le fou il ya
peut-être qu'il y ait des trois qui prod
attention
attention qui les prend b3 ça peut-être
partir là bas non sa part en a cinq
allez peut-être fou tours à huit leur
tour il ya peut-être du tour 8 prises
prise héros h7
il faut ensuite il ya le x 5 emprise
oui va il va lancer cette peut-être dams
est pour tout est changé à la le
problème c'est que ça va jouer aux
capacités de bullet et j'ai peur que ce
soit kosteniuk il soit la plus forte
quoique il reste plus de temps pour les
deux joueuses un petit échec à l'échec
relatif échec à n'est pas toi attention
ça va jouer à rien rouages set peut-être
le fou qui va venir angers 7 non elle va
tomber elle maintenant elle est pas
tombé à les prendre en prime ou d'amd
quatre années bateau adam échec
elle est mieux aller gagnante d'un
problème de l a pas eu le temps de le
faire ces trois années sans voix d'amd
de hal et puis on prend puis on prend
cavaliers prend caïds et iv le roi qui
montre faut près move l'afo prévost
vanina madina qui ces trois pions d un
aléa les gagnantes
elle est gagnante offert beaucoup de
traits moules à vanina faut près vous
ferez vous ferez vous ferez vous vous
ferez vous allez il faut se battre à
fond elle sait le faire elle sait le
faire
rostaing qui a été cinq échecs cavaliers
f4 à les prémices de partout
trois des quatre c'est bien joué mais je
suis toujours les meilleurs h5
maintenant une emprise prise 3e 5
elle va venir aller cueillir le pion
elle va la gagner ça va bien yes man in
à kidal et vanilla
c'est parti allez vanina qui repart des
quatre cavaliers f6 peut-être le fou
angers 500 cavaliers c4 ajoute ruch
normes aucun relief 3d 5e 3 peut être
consolidée d'angers 3 le reste dans ses
convictions de la catalane allez
peut-être ont fait petit rock on va
envoyer du cav a lieu cinq ont envoyé du
times et de on va envoyer du tour d un à
quatre pour empêcher b5 on l'a déjà vu
ça plus tôt dans le match peut-être le
kaki à partir en a trois dans fou g5 on
cloue peut-être dieu 4 qui partira un
jour aux trois pôles ont pour consolider
cavaliers des deux qui va arriver
peut-être cavalière des deux mêmes pour
empêcher b5 et gagner le pion qu'à
valider cinq allait peut-être on prend
en deux sets et on revient en d2 avec le
cavalier ou e5 même mais y'aura bessin
qui va arriver c'est pas clair ici les
amis qui est mieux on ne sait pas
dessins qu'elle consolide l'option puis
on prend b3 le pion c4 est attaquée est
ce que kyle des quatre arrivées y aura
peut-être dame ces trois cavaliers
dessins de non retour où peut-être d'amd
de on ne sait pas qui on prend b3 dame
prend des trois bassins on enchaîne avec
tutour c1 le pion c'est celle qui est
faible carrier qui va venir 11,5 à
casser si ce lock-out des cases à
quelques idées de la casse ces quatre il
ya toutes les cases qui sont fait piquer
l'idée de ton consolide ce pion là il va
falloir le gagner attention le pur ou
quatre ans prises d'un me 3 peut-être
pour tous défendre 50 secondes chacune
les deux joueuses qui jouent à peu près
au même rythme pour le moment mais c'est
plutôt kosteniuk y réussit
dans le milieu de partie a enchaîné les
coups qui ces six dames c4 pour le
moment la joueuse
alexandra donc à une position tout à
fait correct peut-être qu'ils avaient
trois pour faire du pays ces cinq le
pion aux 4 n'est plus sous pression et
ça permettra de défendre le pion des
cats et jouer cavalier b6 peut être on
va faire du dam c5 ici non dame ces deux
pour jouer pays ces cinq qui menacera
qu'elle prend bessette et peut-être
qu'on va pouvoir rpt de5 alors est-ce
qu'on peut juste prendre le pion non
elle fait des 5 elle vers l'encaissé au
prochain elle va encaisser même le pion
en d4
attention qu'aux seniors qui se retrouve
mal kosteniuk y ait de nouveau mal et la
tour qui va bientôt arriver en c1 menacé
dame français cette dame b2 bien jouer
menace cavaliers 5 maintenant et le
plonger cavalière cinq dames 5 dame
prend b4 le pion qui va tomber
aulas il ya même un grand b 4 quand même
peut-être donc ici qu'il prend des cinq
par contre qui et prend des saints qui
on prend des 5 vous prend des cinq même
il ya le cavalier qui tombe c'est chaud
qui on prend d'un point f5 et peut-être
tout reprend 1,8 et des six ici pour
déstabiliser le cavalier et sur des
systèmes f6 on aurait pu faire tourner
alors elle a fait dame c5 menaces le
pion c7 est peut-être sur tours s'est
vite on fera des six quand même à l'ondé
si sûr à l'agora le problème sur la dame
dameuse 5 joué tour c'est un menace le
pion et la d6 pas jouable à cause de
dame prend ses cinq peut-être f4 du coup
dans fouet 3 elle veut se donner de
l'air pour le roi h4 peut-être pour
prendre un peu d espace 3g de bien jouer
pour ces trois tours 3 pour ces deux
tours de tours 2 non il n'y a pas eu le
temps pour ces deux là même si c'est au
noir de jouer pardon c'était une menace
tour des deux allait elle veut faire des
six elle veut se débarrasser du pion d
non elle peut toujours pas s'en
débarrasser mais c'est vrai que ce fou
il est un peu un peu bizarre un peu
alambiqué peut-être dam des quatre
échecs prendre là nul ici pour les
blancs on va voir d'amd capte avec six
dames c5
ça paraît être la bonne option tour 8
qui rôde
côté new qui a l'air d'être d'accord
pour là nulle part quand il faut
peut-être un peu accéléré on sait jamais
vanina non elle fait dames 4 pas deux
nuls mais qui prend des cinq aulas
quelle erreur
elle n'a pas voulu prendre là nul quand
elle y était incroyable et maintenant
ils se retrouvent mal peut-être qu'il
faut jouer hqe à damas six d'am dam à 8
allez peut-être on envoie tout redon
mais adam en 1 8 non allez peut-être
tour à deux tours à huit a il faut se
battre
côté côté vanina tours à huit dames
c'est 5 pour tenter d'amérique mais
adams est hawaï il n'y a toujours rien
dame prend des cinq craquage elle a
craqué on va maintenant devoir à l'écran
mais elle a complètement craqué ouais ça
me prendrait 5 le craquage de vanina
écossais new qui revient à un point et
c'est très dommage qu'elle n'ait pas
joué le lan eu le père pète à la bouche
que pour gagner et elle a payé cash
on voit maintenant alexandra très
concentré on voit le regard vraiment les
yeux grands ouverts vraiment la
concentration d'alexandre assez
impressionnant les mecs vous invite
vraiment à regarder juste en dessous
la caméra et le regard d'alexandra c'est
vraiment très très intense et on sent
vraiment toute l'intensité toute la
concentration de l'ex championne du
monde alors on ré échanges maintenant
les fous de cases blanches et les noirs
qui ferme la position attention
maintenant les blancs qui vont jouer
l'attaqué à tout prix et les noirs qui
vont jouer le jeu à l'aide dame
normalement en bullet ça avantage plutôt
la personne qui joue l'attaqué à tout
prix est ce que j'ai 5 peut être un coup
ici pour les noirs ça peut paraître
étrange mais avec l'idée après 2 2
ramené peut-être un cavalier verger si
sévère f4 en tout cas le cavalier qui
vient vers f3 en menaces l'option
peut-être 5 et des quatre à long terme
avec avec des petits clouage sur le fou
des six cavaliers h7 peut-être peut-être
un jour on peut faire g5 et puis jouer
pour la case f4 avoir cavaliers hkd g6
on empêche absolument aux cavaliers de
venir est fou h 1 alors pourquoi fois
chain parce qu'elle veut venir en
2 mais là peut-être n'en cavani 11,6
pour venir se diriger justement faire
cette case f4 et il semble que les noirs
soient pas mal fabien petit coup de g5
voilà c'est jouer elle a fait le plan f6
on va blindés on va jouer vite après
cavaliers fille kg si ce qui peut
arriver tranquillement et on a tous le
jeu maintenant ces cinq baies 5 c 4
vanina qui à mon avis a pris l'avantagé
en début de partie et maintenant il va
falloir faire fructifier avec a5b cinq
c4 qui va avancer
la joueuse russe qui est en train
d'envoyer cavaliers les p5 ces cinq c4 a
les fonds envoyés faut envoyer le jeu il
n'y a absolument rien pour les blancs
c'est du pipeau total il faut juste
envoyer ton jeu allèles dames et gagner
cette partie mais il faut le faire vite
à 4 qui est bien jouer maintenant pour
faire ses cinq tours c8 c5 qui va
arriver ça va jouer sur la colonne c'est
la joueuse russe qui est vraiment pas
mal ces cinq prises prises la tour qui
peut arriver jusqu'à ses trois peut-être
un jour le fou qui prend c'est 5
toujours pas de menace de quoi on prend
peut-être du pion h du pion f du pion f
elle veut peut-être joué pour dames f6
et cavaliers f4 il reste combien de
temps il reste à peu près 20 minutes de
match kosteniuk qui est un petit peu
moins bien toujours un point d'avancé
pour boudina mais ce match qui est serré
comme jamais la tour kignan h3 les
blancs qui prépareront c'est quoi les
blancs qui sont mal mais les noirs qui
doivent absolument trouver une manière
de percer le les taux peut-être 3g sept
cavaliers afrique et j'ai six cavaliers
h4 à l'efo le faut le ramener ce
cavalier 17la la tour qui menacent ici
les blancs qui ont un peu de mal mais il
faut ramener des pièces en jeu là les
noirs il faut commencer à rentrer dans
les trous c'est important il faut
commencer à aviser les trous parce que
là les trous pour le moment ils ne sont
pas visés car ils étaient six allez on
vise le trou est peut-être cavaliers 4
quand même peut-être toujours et
peut-être mille autres pour reprendre 2
e mail reprend du cavalier alors parce
que oui vous pourrez capter pas possible
elle prépare peut-être des trucs avec
des sacrifices d'amd 6 ou c'est bien
joué de la part de kosteniuk y passe de
l'autre côté avec la lame est maintenant
peut-être 3g si ces tours 1-7 tout
bêtement pour chasser la dame allait
s'apprend faut reprendre l reprendre ce
pion qui est étonnant je vais te repris
dauger pour essayer de jouer du h5 et
maintenant oui les blancs qui peuvent
essayer d'enrayer le pion à eux avoir
maintenant vous prend à 3 semble jouable
n'ont toujours pas joué mais fou prend à
trois qu'il va être joué
le fou qui va revenir vers sète et le
pion à qui va partir maintenant les
blancs essaie d'envoyer leurs pions peut
peut-être 6 mai à 3 qui arrive tour
c'est tout bêtement et tout reprendre
six et trois sets plus tôt
elle laisse dame f5 c'est hyper
dangereux
c'est hyper dangereuse qui est en train
de se passer mais il semble qu'il ya
rien qu'aux seniors qui a huit secondes
tout le temps de kosteniuk là qui est en
train de partir pour qu'on réussisse
menace pouces et 5 échecs ou c5
yes c'est gagné c'est gagné la dame qui
tombe et +2 pour vanina vanina qui
s'accrochent la nina qui est toujours
devant vanina qui réalise une
performance vraiment xxl ce soir à
incroyable la joueuse la joueuse russe
la moscovite à présent qui vraiment fait
une super performance et qui réussit
malgré ses erreurs en début de match à
garder cet avantage et à rester devant
allez il faut continuer maintenant coté
à vanina il faut maintenir la pression
il faudra maintenir cet étau qui est en
train de se resserrer complètement sur
l'ex championne du monde mais pour le
moment il n'y a que deux points et on
l'a vu vanina plus tôt dans le match qui
pouvait parfois çà et là de donner des
points et paquin plutôt deux voire même
trois d'affilée
donc il va falloir contenir et maintenir
cette pression sur alexandra kosteniuk
alexandra kosteniuk qui évidemment ne
donne rien
là avec les noirs pour le moment égalité
matérielle mais l'option b 5 est très
gênant la dame qui va pouvoir venir en a
un
peut-être même en a deux puis la tour 1
pour venir doubler s'en prendre à ce
pion à 7 qui ne demande qu'à être mangés
très bien joué là il ya peut-être que si
ce qui va partir c'est extraordinaire ce
qu'elle est en train de faire vanina
c'est vraiment une performance de très
haute volée mais attention kosteniuk n'a
pas dit son dernier mot la dame qui
arrive en f c'est peut-être on tape sur
le pion f2 et le cavalier qui va venir
en d3 cavalier e 4 très bien joué elle
s'en prend maintenant que la tour est
parti aux pions c3
la tour qui vient 8 peut-être la dame
qui va devoir partir jusqu'à h3 pour ne
pas se prendre de découverte là cavalier
français 3 à un cavalier des quatre qui
protège encore la tour e 2 donc pour le
moment vanina qui tient mais qui tient
jusqu'à quand dans cette partie aller
sur le sur le fil du rasoir et le pion
qui est un peu attaquées
elle a un répit et peut-être un coup
comme dame 6-6-6 envisageable elle fait
g3 est d'alger kahn donc qu'elles
gardent les dames sur l'échiquier et
peut-être h 4 h 5 maintenant elle essaye
de retourner la situation mais attention
quand même parce que les pièces noires
sont actives aller un petit coup de dams
et 8 échecs non d'alger 5
elle met la pression sur le cul est
maintenant h5 qui part avec l'idée de
faire h 6 c'est vrai que ça peut être
dangereux si le kg en arrivant h6 ici
les amis le roi noir pourrait être en
très mauvaise posture et la dame qui va
pouvoir venir éventuellement des 8 après
un jour pour donner un échec
attention ça devient dangereux pour
alexandra al adha adam des 8 a voulu
faire damer fuite
mesdames g4 peut-être dames et fit quand
même est envisageable est ce que tours 1
et tours prend à 7 est possible mais il
y aurait tout re 1 et dame prend un
chien à la fin c'est pas jouer cavalier
ses six sorties de nulle part mais est
ce que c'est un bon coup allait elle
défend le pion et l attaque ici il n'y a
pas d'âme prend 1,6 à cause de cavalier
e set
ouais c'est très bien joué ce que fait
vanina là elle est impressionnante
franchement les amis vanina qui joue un
niveau stratosphérique ce soir et là
maintenant cavalier des huit qui tue
c'est incroyable incroyable les avis
vanina qui joue à un niveau est tour à
tour prend à cette incroyable vanina qui
nous sort une performance digne des plus
grands ce soir c'est vraiment quelque
chose parce qu'elle est en train de
faire c'est vraiment quelque chose
depuis qu'il a été mené 3 points elle
nous sort un match mais de folie on se
rappelle qu'en pro de chez sig avait
fait nul d'ailleurs contre maxime
vachier lagrave en personne amenée dans
une position gagnante d'ailleurs et
vanina quant à la 1000e quand elle a mis
les clefs de contact qu'elle a allumé le
moteur c'est pas une deux chevaux c'est
une ferrari cas là c'est de la très
belle voiture belles carrosseries là
c'est vrai que ça ça envoie du lourd
ça envoie du très lourd côté vanille la
cdu 400 chevaux deux secondes pour
passer de 0 à 100 km heure
ça envoie vraiment du lourd et donc on
va envoyer peut-être le pion des quatre
à voir elle est peut-être par al nabhani
là encore qui avait lieu quatre dames b
6 pouces et 5 pouces et 5 dames b6 la
has est en train de rentrer tout seul la
case f2c kosteniuk finalement kiki qui
tombe
les coups de butoir de vanina halal est
exceptionnelle elle est exceptionnelle
ce soir je veux vraiment attirer votre
votre attention sur sur ce niveau de jeu
c'est kosteniuk qui craque à la surprise
générale c'est alexandra kosteniuk qui
craquent la première lappion b2 qui va
tomber sur tourbe et realp ur a deux qui
tombe il ya encore tout reprend 17 c'est
encore chaud kosteniuk qui résistent bon
an mal an phu b4 maintenant elle va
vouloir faire à 5 envoyé f5
puis on prend des cinq os est très bien
joué les tours ces deux allées faut
aller faut aller jouer de ce côté là
mais il y aura peut-être trop grande et
4 très bien joué de la part de
d'alexandra qui se créent le pion passé
et qui se créent le pion pas céder et
qui met son adversaire en difficulté
maintenant la tour qui va arriver en d3
peut-être la dame qui va revenir en d5
aussi avec des double attaque
c'est encore exceptionnel ce qu'elle
fait le tour ces trois vraiment très
beau tour des trois maintenant et
probablement dam des cinq ici ouais
c'est vraiment vraiment vraiment du
cousu main sur dame c'est 7 à tour d un
contre attaque et surtour c'est cette
dame prend 1,5 et on va pouvoir faire f
6 au cas où
et ça va aller mais kosteniuk hawaï à
[ __ ] en d6 vous prend la fuite est fou
et il ya de gama temps là je dois
m'attendre
elle raté le matin mais abandon
kosteniuk +4 olala c'est une
démonstration de vanina démonstration de
vanina là c'est vraiment c'est vraiment
beau ce qu'elle est en train de faire
c'est extraordinaire les amis
fantastique cette performance elle gagne
toutes les parties elle enchaîne elle
trouve les bons coups elle joue vite
elle joue bien quand elle était mal
autant elle enchaîné c'est vraiment
c'est vraiment beau ce qu'on est en
train de vivre
il reste combien de temps il reste douze
minutes + 4 c'est quasiment
mathématiquement fini les amis c'est
beau c'est vraiment beau de voir ça le
cabinet qui va venir en c3 et il va
juste falloir jouer la montre
tranquillement maintenant pour vanina
ehu nul devrait suffire si elle joue la
montre
et quel talent et qu'elle fait une nulle
ça devrait suffire
donc tous les partis peuvent être des
balles de match à partir du maintenant à
mon avis le moindre match nul peut le
faire et ce qu'il peut y avoir du
cavalier français 3 ici puis on prend et
cavaliers des cinq pour essayer de jouer
le clouage sa part est intéressant c'est
ce qui va être joué d'ailleurs par
kosteniuk parce qu'un double cloud
ageeci donc peut-être fou et 4 es fou
détroit pour couvrir à mailhac et
français 3 aussi qui rôdent pour la
kosteniuk qui devrait l'emporter et
vanina qui normalement ne devrait pas
abandonner mes faire tourner la pendule
un maximum damas deux prises d'amd 3 et
cavaliers qui revient à les attentions
peut-être faut faire tourbains ici comme
ça surtout prend ces cas tu aurais dame
prend b8 bon fait maintenant cavalier e
bon c'est bien elle s'en est sortie
alors elle est moins bien évidemment
mais elle va pouvoir jouer cette
position pendant un sacré moment
cavaliers à 3,20 à skis et prend baissé
à kaunas où prend des cinq menace
d'armes français set la joueuse russe
qui est de nouveau bien
elle menace vraiment elle peut prendre
et elle peut récupérer le pion mais elle
donnerait les cases blanches autour du
roi donc elle va pas le faire mais
peut-être que ces quatre cavaliers au
sein qu'elle fait peu 4 à elle va les
gagner le pion c7
c'est bien ce qu'elle fait et vanina
sait bien ce qu'elle fait elle résiste
bien et d'impro de cinq peut-être ici
elle craque complètement kosteniuk c'est
incroyable que c'est nous qui est
vraiment en train de se déliter devant
nous elle craque elle est juste moins
forte ce soir et vanina qui réalise une
telle performance
or elle mettra grande favorite de la
finale à mon avis face à daniel yon je
vois pas mise à part chose bizarre
comment elle le match pourrait lui
échapper
parce que là elle est en train d'écraser
la favorite de la compétition
je vous rappelle qu'elle était menée au
score qu'elle semblait dans le dur elle
a retourné sa de manière magistrale et
elle continue cavaliers des six
peut-être royal de tourbe et a
maintenant le cavaly qui peut être
attaqué bon ça c'était peut-être pas
très bien joué
allez il va falloir résister à la un
petit effort encore tourbains il ya cinq
tours à 4 très bien pensée sur à 5 à
tout reprendre
est-ce que tour c1 et tourer est un
problème ici
peut-être peut-être vite revenir en
première rangée l'a donc elle va monter
avec le roi c'est courageux mais il ya
quatre ans s est maintenant où elle
contre attaque elles menacent ma
tondeuse
on l'avait pas vu venir et maintenant
peut-être un coup comme tour des six est
jouable fouet f7 et tour des huit risqué
mais tour des huit et peut-être jouable
ici mais risqué parce qu'il va y avoir
un échec en e2 droit monte
ouais c'est même plus que risqué ça m'a
l'air assez pourri droit ses cinq tours
ces six échecs n'ont pas joué et dion
qui parent h 2a est très bien joué de la
part de kosteniuk il va y avoir damé eux
cette es fou à 4 x 4 qui sauve le jour
save the day comme disent les anglais il
a peut-être encore un peu joué à l'effet
encore tenté un petit quelque chose
non elle tente pas il aurait fallu parce
qu'elle aurait pu faire tourner encore
une bonne vingtaine de secondes à la
pendule et il reste que trois points
d'écart
allez là il ya des risques de prix de
côté d'autres tours h2o elle n'aurait
peut-être pas dû s'envoler tour des huit
à ce moment là c'est dommage mais bon
elle gère pas le temps elles gèrent pas
son effort et à les faire play est vrai
mais bon c'est peut-être dommage ça peut
coûter le match aller on est reparti
dans cette position très ferme et une
partie qui va de nouveau durer longtemps
trois points d'écart et il reste neuf
minutes à jouer ça qui reste au maximum
quatre parties les mecs mais vu que les
partis sont quand même assez longue je
dirais plutôt trois parties et donc il
cette fois ci elle a décidé de partir
pour le rock opposés et elle va
allez peut-être ouvrir quand même
c'était le roi avec tours j'ai huit
cavaliers h7 et g6 qui va partir et la
joueuse russe qui va envoyer valentina
elles sont les deux russes donc c'est
pas évident avec ce truc de nationalité
mais qui va envoyer le pion et
maintenant peut-être que tour f 8
ouais elle chasse la tour bref si
cependant elle fait d'amener huit as et
qu'il est peut-être qu'ils g5 d'ailleurs
qui est des cinq peut-être intéressant
elle vise la case f3 sur fou prend dame
prend il n'y a pas tout reprend 17 parce
qu'à clouage et ce cavalli qui est bien
placé kf3 échec maintenant vous prend
tout reprend la tour qui rentre et
peut-être dame f6 maintenant qui va
arriver pour aller faire à mettre la
pression la joueuse russe qui menacent
dame tous rêvent de dames f3 nom fu g5
peut-être damev 7 est peut-être tout
reste 2 qui va arriver incessamment sous
peu mais je pense pas que l'attak
quoique si elle fait d'un rêve de tous
rêvent de haies dames f3 ça va aller
mais je pense que sur tours l2 aura
toujours d'amour qui viendra couvrir
cependant elle peut quand même y aller
avec tous rêvent de maintenant sur d'amr
à aimer sur dame n'y a rien donc croire
ces sept protège allez vous trouver
quelque chose il faut y aller tous
rêvent de d'un f3 qui va arriver tôt ou
tard on va voir ce qui se passe à 4
tours f2 aller mais bon il ya damien
tout le temps un sartre est pas grand
chose en fait ce tour f the damn un tour
f3 et palmarès on a perdu deux coups
ouais bon c'est juste parce qu'on peut
pas attaquer en fait les noirs qui ont
un problème ils peuvent pas attaquer il
faut ramener du matos l'écossé gnocchis
réfléchi longtemps
attention alexandra ça pourrait lui
coûter cher tout reprend dé 6,3 prend
des six à cinq mais qu'est ce que c'est
que ça à quoi ça sert bref ça semble
être un craquage de la part de kosteniuk
qui n'a plus l'énergie
tour 3 à tour trois quais des 5 3 et 6
ouais ça va quand même un cavalier aux
6es fou prend 2,3 il faut prendre trois
amis roi progressis encore c'est pas
fini on a pensé que c'était fini mais ça
ne l'est pas râler
faut trois dames c5 lutte et la dame qui
revient maintenant est ce qu'on va
pouvoir partir avec du roi bessette
roigé cette fougue et qu'adam des dames
ces six cavaliers six cavaliers prend
2,4 peut-être pour pour aller chercher
le père pète allées cavalières si ça
paraît logique c'est jouer elle revient
dès cet écueil sur what she cff huit
échecs peut-être aller perpète ça te va
bien non elle prend pas là nul hein
c'est incroyable vanina la nu lui offre
la victoire du match aller c'est sur une
partie qui durent très longtemps
et attention peut-être d'un match il
faut pas laisser partir ce roi à la
vanille n'a elle le laisse se barrer
mais ok peut-être d'un machin d'un match
6 à le fou qui vient damage 6 quand même
elle va revenir avec la dame en d5 c'est
en train de tourner côté c'est en train
de tourner côté kosteniuk cette partie
le roi qui a réussi à se replacer et là
tous les pions de vanina qui tombe c'est
une horreur peut-être dame f1 ici dame
f3 il faut tenter de trouver là nul dame
f1 le retour d'ahmed trois dames j'ai
deux dames f3 d'un mets fins non fallu
faire d'un f3 elle s'est plantée à
l'erreur de manille n'a eu fallait faire
d'art faire de même trois échecs et elle
s'est plantée et elle s'est plantée et
maintenant elle est foutue
c'est triste pour vanina qu'il est ce
qu'il est la partie s'échapper ah là là
il y avait il y avait perpète avec trois
fois la même position et le match était
gagné
incroyable incroyable elle a vendangé le
gain du match là de manière assez assez
inattendu et c'est un vrai problème
maintenant c'est fini
allez faut quand même faire quelques
j'essaye de jouer un petit peu il reste
4 minutes et quelques y avoir deux
points d'écart incroyable les amis
incroyable c'est un gros un gros un gros
raté elle va réussir à choper un pion
mais pas plus le pion ces six pays ces
quatre halles elle réussi à défendre un
petit peu mais ça va pas suffire
cependant si elle joue la pendule elle
joue pas la pendule aller fair play elle
aurait pu laisser tourner encore 40
secondes
on voit ainsi elle n'avait pas joué fair
play m'enfin moi j'appelle pas ça à
faire clair si elles avaient joué
d'après les règles là il resterait plus
que 2 minutes 30 la cie elle avait
utilisé les règles et avec 2 minutes 30
à la pendule
c'était fini donc goût nina qui n'a pas
tué le match
elle n'a pas tué le match elle aurait pu
prendre 30 secondes deux fois et l a pas
fait et franchement moi pour moi c'est
le jeu elle al'avantage je vois pas
pourquoi elle en profite par en tout cas
cette partie qui maintenant est
complètement décisive cavaliers h5 elle
va prendre le fouet f4 sûr qu'il faut
promettre quatre peut-être qu'ils ont
prévu quatre ans elle prend 1,5 à elle
perd un pion vanina qui perd des gens
qui on allait déjà mal
attention attention lacoste est nu qui
est complètement en train de revenir
dans le match peut-être tour d un e 4
allée il faut attaquer les mecs à fond
parce que là le match il en train de
tourner il est en train de tourner en
faveur de d'alexandra qui si elle
revient à égalité à mon avis dans le
tie-break en cas de partir un très grand
avantage psychologique sur son
adversaire et la vanina qui est mal elle
fait 5 tout de même mais il n'ya pas
cavalier e katia lecavalier qui emprise
le pion aux 5 c'est la cata les nex
c'est la cata c'est catastrophique
vanina qui fait n'importe quoi avec
validé 6 faut lutter petit il reste
combien de temps il reste 2 minutes 30
allez faut la tenir le plus longtemps
possible faut pas la faire fair play
downs cette carafe 6 allez faut rentrer
là il ya des trous faut rentrer à les
dames c'est de bien jouer
tf6 année il faut lutter et paquet six
échecs tout reprend 1,6 dans son
ensemble et peut-être qu'avec six noms
ça marchait pas du tout aller il faut
lutter à fond il faut lutter à fond h5
est ce qu'elle veut h6 peut-être ou
quelque chose ou peut-être plus on prend
et jouer sur la colonnade chi resto quoi
moi j'ai besoin d'avoir le temps autour
de moi il reste deux minutes le pion qui
est maintenant h5 dans son crash n'a pas
été joué
et kosteniuk qui doit trouver un moyen
de se développer
fougue et cette fois h3 menace vous
prend aussi ce fou prend 2,6 fillon
prend pions prend et la finale qui va
être à l'avantagé de qui s'apprend au 4
en premier elle va reprendre 4 qui on
prend aux six dames francis damay vii
qui ont projet 6 et ça a l'air d'aller
ça pour pour les blancs qui ont franchi
si si si je pense intermédiaire dont
elle fait d'am dam g4 contre attaque
l'option f2 maintenant il va falloir
faire peut-être ce qui a trait tour si
ça allait prendre le pion aux 6 il reste
combien de temps c'est tout tout étant
je l'aï minutes 30 il reste pas très
longtemps a accosté new pour l'emporter
surtout qu'on sait qu'on a un petit
décalage peut être une dizaine quinzaine
de secondes de latence et il reste une
25 années peut-être f4 aller fkt tour
aux six tours 2 à l'arrivée avoir des
trois ça sent très mauvais là ça sent
très très mauvais pour vanina a les
dames h4 d'un problème c'est qu'elle va
jouer la finale
puis on prend qui comprend il reste une
minute dix partiel jouer le truc ça
elles pourraient le gagner mais on
connaît vanina elle va faire elle va
elle va être elle va être fermée
jusqu'au bout malheureusement j'ai envie
de dire à pas surtout par wade d'oeil à
tour aussi c'est fini c'est fini
la finale de tueries perdante et elle
n'a pas joué le temps elle abandonne
il reste 40 secondes elle aurait fait
des trucs salle elle aurait gagné le
match des mecs à ce niveau de la
compétition ça ne sert à rien de jouer
fair play il faut gagner les matches
au bout d'un moment c'est le truc et
reste plus qu'un point dans cette partie
et là on a donc le dernier match
cavaliers f6 aller food et si on se
développe on joue solide on est toujours
à une nulle le temps il est terminé il
ya plus de temps c'est la dernière
partie les amis balle de match pour pour
gouina mail avantage psychologique sur
les derniers dernière partie est quand
même à 1 en faveur de kosteniuk y
enchaîne trois victoires les dames c'est
cette dame c4 peut-être non cavaliers g6
pour aller vers les 4 avec le cavalier
fouet f4 allez on échange toutes les
pièces maintenant côté côté vanina ceux
qui ont ces deux qui peut être en
difficulté
la dame qui va venir ans et c'est
peut-être avec dame français 3 qui
menace dans le cavalier qui recule à
lecavalier de nouveau menacé peut-être
cavaliers 7 et d'am-dam ses sept pour
s'en prendre aux pions c3 nom d'anne
decis peut-être pour ses sept tours c8
le pour le moment là c'est solide des 5
b 4 non elle fait escale à peut-être
6 h 5 pour bien bloqué le pion f4 en f4
le cavaly qui vient à eux deux est ce
que quelque 4 est un coup ici peut-être
cavalière c1 qu'elle laisse vous prend
et 5.5 pour avoir le cavaly qui arrive
en 4 et sans prendre option c3 vanina
qui est bien dans cette partie qui est
bien devant mais ça il va falloir la
tenir jusqu'à la fin
c'est du bullet tout peut arriver
peut-être des 5 à 6 pour consolider
cavaliers cavaliers prend et maintenant
peut-être des cinq pour bien bien bien
bloqué ce pion c3 et s'en prendre à lui
un peu plus tard la tour qui vient en c6
peut-être dames c'est cette france et 3
qui arrive tous rêvent 3 qui défend
latéralement le pion dame prend des
quatre évidemment pas jouable elle prend
prises çà et f5 maintenant c4 est pas
jouable parce qu'il a tout repensé 4
elle veut dam des cinq tours b quatre
baies 5 à 6 et en fermer complètement
kosteniuk qui va devoir forcément de
toute façon un moment donné prendre un
risque maintenant elle veut peut-être
dame sait si c'est tout reprend des
quatre avec les avec les noirs ou tout
reprend dégâts directs humble d'ailleurs
puisque la dame est partie et iard
maintenant un pion de plus pour gunino
et peut-être même deux très bientôt
aller la tour qui valait peut-être en d3
maintenant ou en d1 ou en d2 plus tôt
peut-être en d2 en d2 oui donc elles
menacent éventuellement le pion j'ai
deux c4 qui part il va falloir à tout
prix augmenter la pression peut-être
tour des huit dameuse c'est de la mef
cette dame h5 qui peut arriver c'est un
plan allait mais maintenant il ya le
pion c'est qui part c'est très bien joué
de la part de deux kosteniuk qui joue
son va tout à fond le pion cc6 sur fion
français 6 à le faire tout reprend ses 6
et s'en prendre aux pions e6 tour des
six va être joué il reste 19 secondes
contre contre 32 peut-être damev cette
dame h5 tour d un aller il va falloir
envoyer ce plan d'un rêve s'était joué
tour ces huit trois sets ya rien n'y a
pas un échec a plus rien j'ai quatre
pions pranger iv le roi qui se donne la
casse g3 mais bon ça n'a pas l'air
d'être sérieux il ya dames 1re cat qui
menace d'un pro f 4 échecs ici les amis
c'est quasiment fini tour projet de tour
des deux échecs les tours détroit aidé à
me ranger 3 il semble que le match soit
gagnée pour valentina valentina qui
l'emportent victoire de valentina les
amis valentina qui se qualifie pour la
grande finale et qui sera favorite de
cette finale
elle gagne de manière splendide ce match
après avoir
dominé le match quand même dans son
ensemble elle a eu deux petits passages
à vide où elle a donné deux trois points
cadeaux mais sur le reste franchement
c'était dominé de a à z
valentina qui l'emportent valentina au
dessus de tout valentina merci valentina
bravo valentina on t'aime c'est
magnifique on te retrouve jeudi prochain
sur les coups de 18 heures pour la
grande finale contre danielian et
valentina qui va représenter qui
représente à fond et qui est magnifique
fantastique incroyable
on n'a plus les superlatifs les amis
c'est fantastique là ce qu'elle vient de
réaliser valentina extraordinaire
exploit majuscule
elle bat kosteniuk à la surprise
générale grande favorite de la
compétition en gagnant en bullet face à
une joueuse spécialiste d'internet
valentina qui montre les crocs et
valentina qui sera vraiment vraiment
vraiment difficile à sortir pour daniele
ans après on verra bien ce qui se passe
ces jours arménien on s'est toujours
dangereux en blitz toujours dangereux
sur internet
mais face à valentina ça va me paraître
quand même très difficile il va falloir
du gérard depardieu arménien pour
pouvoir venir à bout de la joueuse russe
et depardieu qui russes aussi donc
quelque part ce sera du gérard depardieu
côté est côté russe on va voir comment
ça se termine
mais en tout cas c'est incroyable ce
qu'elle a réalisé magnifique magnifique
les amis je vous laisse avec une petite
page de pub parce qu'il faut et je vais
tout de suite vous envoyer derrière vers
les interviews pour écouter ce que
valentina à dire valentina qui va avoir
des choses intéressantes à nous partager
dans l'interview officiel en anglais
écoutez les mecs je vous laisse le raid
on se dit à demain pour les parties
pédagogique et à jeudi 27 pour la grosse
finale avec danielian face à gérard
valentina gunino
j'ai envie de dire valentina depardieu
wii minna qui sera là et qui va opposer
des gros plat roscoff aa danielian qui
aura fort à faire face aux porsche opel
minuit à la vodka
ils seront tous là
ils seront tous sera bourges pelmeni ça
a quand même un menu assez copieux à la
auquel il va falloir reposer de la
cuisine de la cuisine arménienne mais la
crise arménienne est allé au niveau on
se retrouve jeudi soir les tontons on se
retrouve jeudi soir je vous mets le raid
vers la chaîne et on se retrouve jeudi
soir attendez je peux pas mettre leur
aide
j'ai été déconnecté pourtant je suis
connecté donc à demain pour aller partie
pédagogique mais vraiment très très beau
match